Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 25. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe, in den ganzen Gesprächen rund um Wissenschaft und um Bildung. Horizonte für Forschung und Bildung das haben wir bei uns auf der Webseite stehen und versuchen, diese auch immer wieder zu liefern und neu zu ergründen. In den letzten Ausgaben hatten wir dann auf einmal einen ziemlichen Schwerpunkt gefunden, der sich im weiteren Sinne mit Fragen der Nachhaltigkeit und was das mit Wissenschaft und wissenschaftlicher Arbeit zu tun hat und wie es das beeinflusst. Diesen Fokus haben wir hier ein wenig entwickelt und ich denke, wir werden ihn heute noch etwas vertiefen. Denn heute soll es gehen um transformative Wissenschaft. Und was sich hinter diesem plakativen Begriff vielleicht verbirgt das erläutert uns gleich Uwe Schneidewind. Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo guten Tag.
Ja schön, dass Sie hier bei Forschergeist dazu haben stoßen können. Vielleicht mal zu Ihnen, Sie sind, weiß nicht, was war denn Ihr Weg in die Welt der Wissenschaften? War das so von Vornherein schon immer klar?
Nein das war es nicht. Also ich habe eigentlich ein Studium gemacht, das mich so gar nicht in die Wissenschaft hätte führen sollen. Ich habe mal angefangen an der Universität Köln Betriebswirtschaftslehre zu studieren, weil ich eigentlich was praktisches machen wollte. Ich war so vom Impetus getrieben, zu gestalten, vielleicht ein Manager zu werden. Und bin dann in dieses Betriebswirtschaftsstudium hinein gestolpert. Und so ein Betriebswirtschaftsstudium das ist ja jetzt nicht gerade der Quell sozusagen intellektueller Inspiration, sondern oft eher Mittel zum Zweck. Und mich hat es dann so am Ende des Studiums erwischt, dass ich merkte, nein das kann doch jetzt nicht alles gewesen sein. Habe dann begonnen, mich mit Fragen der Unternehmensethik, der Verantwortung von Unternehmen auseinanderzusetzen. Und hatte so das Gefühl, nein das sind so die Bereiche, da möchtest du die Dinge vertiefen. Und bin über diesen Pfad dann in das Thema Nachhaltigkeit gekommen und habe dann währen der Promotion an der Universität Sankt Gallen in einem sehr interdisziplinären Umfeld dann eigentlich das erste Mal die Lust an Wissenschaft bekommen.
Und gemerkt, oh ja, also dieses sich intellektuell in der Welt zu orientieren, das ist vermutlich etwas, was auch dieses Ursprungsanliegen da draußen Veränderungen auszulösen noch sehr viel wirksamer und effektiver tun kann, als das was mich da ursprünglich in das Anfangsstudium hatte hineingehen lassen.
Trotzdem haben Sie dann als Professor für Betriebswirtschaftslehre auch gearbeitet.
Ja, ich meine da ist natürlich so ein gewisser Pfad vorgegeben, wenn das die fachliche Ausgestaltung ist. Wobei ich an der Universität Sankt Gallen schon ein sehr viel breiteres Verständnis von Management und Managementlehre kennengelernt habe. Die Sankt Galler definieren ja Management so als die Gestaltung und Steuerung produktiver sozialer Systeme. Also das beschränkt sich dann gar nicht mehr nur auf Unternehmen und Organisationen, sondern die gucken auf solche komplexen sozialen Systeme und fragen, wie verändern die sich eigentlich, was kann man da für Steuerungsimpulse setzen?
Also eigentlich auch schon mehr so eine volkswirtschaftliche Brille oder?
Volkswirtschaft, ja durchaus eher auch eine gesellschaftswissenschaftliche. Also ich habe meine Habitationsschrift damals über die Rolle von Unternehmen in solchen gesellschaftlichen Veränderungsprozessen geschrieben. Habe mir also angeschaut, wie wirken eigentlich Unternehmen in der Gesellschaft und das war sehr stark inspiriert, dann durch sozialwissenschaftliche und soziologische Theorien. Und mit dem Mindset bin ich damals dann auch in diese Professur nach Oldenburg gegangen. Wobei Oldenburg immer schon ein Standort war, wo die Fragen sehr viel interdisziplinärer zusammen gedacht wurden. Also das was ich da gemacht habe passte sehr gut mit den Dingen zusammen, die mich in Sankt Gallen inspiriert hatten.
Trotzdem gab es dann nochmal einen Wechsel und der war dann auch etwas nachhaltiger, 2010 sind Sie dann Präsident des Wuppertal-Instituts für Klima, Umwelt und Energie – ist das der vollständige Name?
Genau perfekt ja.
– geworden und sind es noch.
Genau. Ja ich meine man muss immer sehen, ich bin ja in einer Zeit in diese Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte hineingekommen, das war Anfang der 90er Jahre, als da ja eine gewaltige Dynamik im Feld war. 1992 gab es ja diese große Konferenz für Umwelt und Entwicklung in Rio de Janeiro und man sich ja auch die Zeit nochmal vergegenwärtigen muss. 89 war der eiserne Vorhang gefallen, man hatte auch so damals ja das Gefühl, jetzt ist dieser alte Konflikt und Streit zwischen Ost und West überwunden und jetzt können wir die Herausforderung angehen, die die Welt als Ganzes betreffen. Und diese Aufbruchstimmung, die hat ja damals Anfang der 90er Jahre sehr sehr stark geprägt, auch mit Blick auf diese Konferenz nach Rio de Janeiro. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass eben nicht nur in der Politik, sondern auch in den Unternehmen, aber auch in der Wissenschaft das Gefühl war, in dem Themenfeld gilt es jetzt Akzente zu setzen.
Und diese Phase damals 1991 ist eben das Wuppertal-Institut gegründet worden. Der Ausgangsimpuls war einer von Johannes Rau, der damals Ministerpräsident in Nordrhein-Westfalen war und den Eindruck hatte, ich brauche hier für dieses große Industrieland im Umbruch und im Wandel brauche ich auch einen führenden Thinktank, der für das Land, für die Politik, Gesellschaft, aber auch die Unternehmen in dem Land ein Stück vordenkt, was heißt diese Perspektive nachhaltige Entwicklung eigentlich für die Weiterentwicklung unseres Landes. Und dann ist mit Ernst Ulrich von Weizsäcker als Gründungspräsident und einem hochinspirativen Team, das Ernst Ulrich von Weizsäcker damals zusammengestellt hat, das Institut so ein bisschen auch zur Ikone dieser neuen Form von Wissenschaft geworden. Und das hat uns alle damals, wie wir in den 90er Jahren in dem Thema arbeiteten, extrem inspiriert und war dann auch wegweisend oft in unserem eigenen Denken.
Also den Mut zu haben, hier Dinge ganz neu und integriert zusammen zu denken. Und als sich dann 2010 die Möglichkeit ergab, sozusagen in die Fußstapfen dieser wunderbaren Geschichte und auch Ernst Ulrich von Weizsäckers treten zu dürfen, war das glaube ich ein Angebot, was man nicht ablehnen konnte. Da schloss sich plötzlich ein Kreis.
Wobei er war jetzt nicht Ihr unmittelbarer Vorgänger, sondern es gab noch andere.
Genau, Peter Hennecke der hat dann seit dem Jahr 2000 das Institut geführt. Ja auch sozusagen eine Ikone der gesamten Energiewende. Und beide ja inzwischen auch Umweltpreisträger der DBU und das ist ja ein bisschen immer das Insignium derjenigen, die die Umwelt- und Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten geprägt haben. Und das ist schon ein besonderes Gefühl, in dieser Reihe jetzt für diese wunderbare Institution Verantwortung übernehmen zu dürfen.
Bevor wir nochmal aufs Wuppertal-Institut genauer eingehen, vielleicht so der Vollständigkeit halber, Sie haben ja auch noch so ein paar andere Mitgliedschaften. Ich glaube bei der Spahn-Stiftung
Ja die Spahn-Stiftung ist ja eine Stiftung, die sehr eng auch mit dem Wuppertal-Institut verbunden ist. Ich glaube jetzt von dem sonstigen Engagement, das was mich derzeit sehr sehr stark prägt, auch die Art des Zugehens und Denkens auf Wissenschaft, sicher einmal die Mitgliedschaft im wissenschaftlichen Beirat globale Umweltveränderung, der WBGU. Das ist ja das Beratungsgremium der Bundesregierung. Die Bundesregierung berät in all diesen Fragen globalen Wandels, Nachhaltigkeit im globalen Kontext. Und der WBGU ist ja so eine Institution, auch damals Anfang der 90er Jahre nach der Rio-Konferenz, entstanden, der die Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte immer wieder entscheidend geprägt hat. Solche Dinge wie das 2-Grad-Ziel, die Idee planetarischer Leitplanken, eben Namen und Personen gerade ganz im Zentrum, Schellnhuber sind ja zentrale Akteure, die aus dem WBGU heraus immer wieder diese nachhaltigkeitspolitischen Debatten geprägt haben.
Und es ist ein sehr interdisziplinäres Umfeld und auch eben der Mut, Dinge neu und anders zu rahmen, ich muss sagen eine sehr sehr inspirierende Arbeit. Dann im internationalen Bereich der Club of Rome, der schon jetzt über 40 Jahre, seit 1972, mit dem Bericht damals von Dennis Meadows und anderen an den Club of Rome zu den Grenzen des Wachstums kam überhaupt das erste Mal das Motiv auf, dass wir vermutlich über ein neues Fortschrittsmodell nachdenken müssen. Und derzeit ist ja Ernst Ulrich von Weizsäcker einer der beiden Vorsitzenden des Club of Romes. Ich bin seit 2011 jetzt auch Mitglied des Club of Rome. Das ist natürlich einfach eine Plattform, wo man dann auch merkt, mit führenden Köpfen dieser Debatte im internationalen Kontext, hier werden diese Impulse, die da seit 40 Jahren im Raum sind, jetzt auf die aktuellen Verhältnisse neu angepasst und angedacht.
Das was ja hier auch im Mittelpunkt des Gesprächs von vor zwei Sendungen. Das muss nochmal am Rande erwähnt werden, wer da vielleicht noch nicht reingehört hat, das Gespräch mit Franz Josef Radermacher ging da auch weit in diese Bereiche rein und auch Club of Rome ist ja ein Zentrum seiner Aktivität gewesen.
Absolut ja. Und auch einer der inspirierenden Köpfe, der ich glaube auch mit seiner Wirkkraft ganz ganz viel, nicht nur national, sondern auch gerade im internationalen Kontext vorantreibt. Das macht natürlich einfach Spaß, in so einem Gremium mit Personen wie ihm, also Ernst Ulrich von Weizsäcker und vielen anderen über diese Fragen diskutieren.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das ein recht inspirierendes Umfeld ist, wenn man da sich rumtreibt. Also nichts ist entspannender als irgendwie in einem Raum intelligenter Menschen zu sein. Und wenn man in solche Hotspots gerät, dann kann man sich da richtig wohlfühlen.
Da ist was dran.
So aber was hat sich denn das Wuppertal-Institut denn jetzt eigentlich auf die Fahnen geschrieben? Also was steht hier im Zentrum Ihrer Arbeit beziehungsweise der Arbeit des Instituts konkret?
Ja wenn man den Titel sich anschaut, Wuppertaler Institut für Klima, Umwelt, Energie, dann hat man ja auf den ersten Blick so den Eindruck, aha das ist ein Klimaforschungsinstitut. Also sozusagen es gibt ja eine ganze Reihe an Instituten, die jetzt so komplexe Modelle bauen, also wie verändert sich das Klimasystem.
Potsdam.
Ja gerade das Potsdamer Institut ist da ja eines der Institutionen ganz weit vorne weg. Das war eigentlich nie die Aufgabe und die Mission des Wuppertal-Institutes, sondern unsere Mission, schon seit Anfang der 90er Jahre, war immer, Übergänge zu einer nachhaltigen Entwicklung zu gestalten und dafür Ideen und Entwürfe zu erarbeiten. Das heißt unsere Arbeit hat dort begonnen, wo sozusagen die Arbeit jetzt vieler klassisch-naturwissenschaftlicher Klimaforschungsinstitute aufhört. Die zeigen sehr deutlich auf, was passiert da draußen eigentlich? Also wie findet Erderwärmung statt, welche Rückwirkung hat das auf die unterschiedlichen Ökosysteme, auf die Meere? Wie wird sich das vermutlich entwickeln, wenn wir in der Wirtschaft so weitermachen wie bisher? Und ab dem Punkt übernimmt dann sozusagen das Wuppertal-Institut. Wir fragen danach, wie müssen politische Strategien, Unternehmensstrategien, die Entwicklung der Wirtschaft eigentlich aussehen?
Wie müssen die Technologien sich weiterentwickeln, damit wir diese Nachhaltigkeitsziele, die wir heute auf Basis der naturwissenschaftlichen Forschung ermitteln können, auch wirklich erreichen können? Also wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus, eine 2 oder 1,5 Grad Welt? Wie müssen die Technologien im Jahr 2050 aussehen? Was braucht es für Formen von politischen Strategien? Wie müssen die Unternehmensstrategien sich in den nächsten Jahrzehnten verändern? Das sind die Themen, die uns eben interessieren und an denen wir dran sind. Und hinter dem Klima, Umwelt, Energie, Energie, Umwelt steckt eben insbesondere das Umweltthema als eines das über die Klima- und Energiefrage noch hinausgeht. Was von Anfang an eine zentrale Rolle spielte, immer einen Blick auf die Ressourcen zu werfen. Denn wir haben das ja an solchen Themen wie dem Biosprit gemerkt, auf den ersten Blick spannende und schöne Idee, um das Klimathema in den Griff zu bekommen.
Schön CO2-neutral.
Genau.
So muss erst mal wachsen, bevor man es verbrennt.
Und plötzlich haben wir uns gewundert, warum dann in den asiatischen Regenwäldern überall abgeholzt wird, um dann große Palmenplantagen aufzubauen, um die Biospritquoten in der EU zu erfüllen. Wo man sehr schnell merkt, wenn man sich über Nachhaltigkeit auch ökologisch auseinandersetzt, braucht man das gesamte Bild. Und muss eben gucken, dass nicht das eine ökologische Problem durch eine Verschlimmerung des anderen gelöst wird. Und der Blick auf die Ressourcen, also die Frage, was passiert eigentlich mit den Bioressourcen, mit den Meeren, mit kritischen Rohstoffen? Das ist eben einer, der uns immer geprägt hat. Und wir eben sagen, am Ende muss es faktisch darum gehen, den Ressourcenverbrauch insgesamt herunterzufahren. Und aufzupassen, dass man eben sich nicht nur isoliert auf eine der globalen Umweltherausforderungen konzentriert. Und da machen wir eben sehr sehr viel auch, indem sich anschauen, wozu führen denn bestimmte Strategien dann im Hinblick auf andere Umweltdimensionen?
Und wie arbeitet, also wie groß muss ich mir das Institut vorstellen? Und was wird so konkret jetzt angestoßen, um diesen Zielen nachzugehen?
Ich meine wir sind, also man muss sich das vorstellen, wir sind knapp 250 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, die aus über 30 Disziplinen kommen. Also da gibt es Naturwissenschaftler, da gibt es Ingenieure, die sich eben gerade mit den technologischen Fragen auseinandersetzen, es gibt Ökonome, die sich mit den ökonomischen Prozessen beschäftigen. Es gibt Sozialwissenschaftler und geht hin bis zu Theologen, die nun versuchen, diese komplexen Transformationsprozesse dann auch im interdisziplinären Zusammenspiel zu verstehen. Und was machen wir jetzt konkret? Also so wie die Naturwissenschaftler in der Klimaforschung eben diese sehr sehr komplexen Klimasysteme modellieren, modellieren wir auch, aber auf der Ebene technologischer Systeme. Also mal ein Beispiel: wir haben 2009 eine sehr schöne Studie gemacht zu der Frage, kann München bis zum Jahr 2058, das wäre der 900. Geburtstag der Stadt, kann das komplett CO2-neutral werden?
Und um so eine Frage zu beantworten, brauchen Sie ein gutes Modell davon, was gibt es denn eigentlich für Technologien im Gebäudebereich, im Verkehrsbereich, im Bereich der Wärmeversorgung in Städten, um zu CO2-neutralen Lösungen zu kommen? Und wie muss das Technologie-Portfolio und das Technologie-Modell eigentlich aussehen, und sich in den nächsten 50 Jahren verändern, da können Sie was zu Veränderungsraten und ähnlichen annehmen, damit wir am Ende bei einem CO2-freien München herauskommt? Und dann kann man diese Technologien und diese nötigen Technologie- und Infrastrukturinvestitionen noch mit Investitionssummen hinterlegen und hat auch ein Gefühl dafür, ja was wird das eigentlich kosten? Und ist das überhaupt ökonomisch darstellbar? Also das ist so ein wichtiger Bereich, solche komplexen technologischen Systeme und ihre Veränderung zu modellieren. Und das kann man oft eben in einer Stadt machen.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt die deutsche Energiewende anschauen, da ist ja die spannende Frage, wie sieht denn das aus das Energiesystem im Jahr 2050, wenn dann 95% aus regenerativen Energien kommt? Was sind die Energiequellen, wie viel Speicher brauch ich in dem System? Wie müssen die Netze ausgelegt werden? Wie muss ich die Verbraucher steuern? Also da sind ja ganz viele unterschiedliche Variablen und da kann man dann eben entsprechende Modelle bauen und verschiedene Szenarien auch erarbeiten. Die bewerten und sehen, wie realistisch ist das. Und in dann noch avancierteren Modellierungen versucht man, dann auch das Verhalten von Akteuren in der Politik, der Verbrauche, Unternehmen noch mit einzubeziehen, um dann auch unterschiedliche Annahmen darüber zu haben, was sind denn vermutlich unter den jetzigen politischen Rahmenbedingungen realistische Entwicklungspfade? Das ist ein wichtiger Teil unserer Arbeit. Und dann geht es aber auch konkret darum Politikstrategien, ganz konkrete politische Konzepte zu erarbeiten.
So ein wichtiges Thema, das wir auch immer wieder versucht haben, auf der Agenda zu halten, ist dass wenn wir über die Energiewende reden es nicht nur darum gehen darf, wie schaffen wir denn das jetzt, alle Kohle- und Atomkraftwerke auszustellen und dafür regenerative Energieerzeugungsanlagen von Wind bis Solar und Biomasse auf den Weg zu bringen. Sondern wir müssen den Energieverbrauch, um das überhaupt zu schaffen, insgesamt radikal runter fahren. Und das ist eben dann unser Fokus, wir müssen die Energieeffizienz steigern. Also ich muss sehen, dass das was ich da draußen an Energie für Transport, für Hauswärme und ähnliches brauche, dass ich das radikal reduziere und trotzdem die gleichen Wärme-  und Mobilitätsbedürfnisse befriedigen kann. Und da ist es dann eine interessante Frage, was brauche ich denn eigentlich für politische Maßnahmen, die auch die Energieeffizienz steiger?
Und so ähnlich wie wir bei den regenerativen Energien, mit dem erneuerbaren Energiegesetz so einen tollen Hebel hatten, um die regenerativen Energien voranzutreiben, braucht es eben auch intelligente politische Instrumente, um zum Beispiel so etwas wie eine Energieeffizienz dann zu fördern.
Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, versuchen Sie schon auf Basis wissenschaftlicher Arbeit, auch konkret anhand technischer Realitäten und also auf Basis der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit abzeichnenden technischen Entwicklungen Einschätzungen vorzunehmen und auch konkrete Berechnungen im Bezug auf, wie das Beispiel München zeigt, also wir nehmen jetzt mal so eine Stadt, gehen von den bekannten Ist-Daten und Soll-Daten aus und schauen uns sozusagen mal an, was muss man eigentlich machen, um jetzt diese Differenz zu bilden? Und das Ganze quasi so als exemplarisches Muster hinzustellen, um zu sagen, um diesen technischen Fortschritt wirklich auch implementieren zu können, müssten auch folgende politische Rahmenbedingungen gegeben sein, die teilweise nicht existieren und da würde ein Strategie in die und die Richtung sozusagen helfen, um das zu erreichen?
Exakt genau. Das ist sozusagen ein wichtiger Ansatz unserer Arbeit.
Was kommen da für Empfehlungen bei raus? Was, um vielleicht mal bei dem Münchner Beispiel zu bleiben, wo geht es denn dann sozusagen in den politischen Diskurs über?
Ja ich meine gerade wenn man jetzt so eine Vision nimmt einer CO2-neutralen Stadt, dann tangiert das ja sehr sehr unterschiedliche Politikfelder. Ein ganz wichtiger Komplex ist dieser Bereich Gebäude. Also die Frage, wie schaffe ich das denn eigentlich von den zum Teil sehr sehr hohen Energieverbräuchen, die ich heute pro m² in der Wohnung habe, um insbesondere auch das Heizen aber auch die elektrische Versorgung sicherzustellen, dass die Verbräuche entsprechend werden. Das ist ja auch auf der nationalen politischen Agenda ein wichtiges Thema. Und reicht dann ja davon wie muss ich die Häuser anders dämmen? Wie komm ich zu einer intelligenten Heizungssteuerung? Wie mache ich die Heizungsanlagen in so einem Gebäude effizienter? Wie kopple ich das dann möglichst auch mit einer regenerativen Energieversorgung?
Und das ist eben ein Thema, das eben einerseits den ganzen Bereich der Wohnungen und Häuser betrifft, die überhaupt erst neu entstehen. Da haben wir politisch in den letzten Jahren ja auch durch eine entsprechende Verschärfung der entsprechenden Verordnung, die das festlegen, einiges erreicht. Aber die eigentliche Herausforderung ist ja dann, was mache ich mit den Häusern, die schon da sind, wo schon Menschen drin wohne, die zum Teil einen sehr sehr hohen Energieverbrauch haben, wo eine Sanierung oft sehr teuer ist? Wo man sich sagt, gut selbst wenn ein Hauseigentümer das in die Hand nimmt, und das dann aber auf die Mieter umlegt, führt das dann dazu, dass ganze Straßenzüge und Quartiere Luxus-saniert werden und es plötzlich dazu führt, dass sich viele dann gar nicht mehr Wohnen in Wohnungen erlauben können, in denen sie sich über Jahre und Jahrzehnte wohlgefühlt haben. Und da wird sehr schnell schon deutlich, dass dann etwas, was dann technologisch Sinn macht, was sich vielleicht sogar auch ökonomisch in bestimmten Städten noch rechnet, zu erheblichen dann auch sozialen Verwerfungen der Stadtpolitik führt.
Und das ist eben etwas, was dann in der politischen Umsetzung ganz ganz wichtig ist, diese Implikation früh schon mit abzubilden und dann auf der Grundlage solcher Analysen eben in auch einen konkreten Diskurs mit der Politik, mit den Betroffenen auch zu gehen. Und so was versuchen wir eben auch entsprechend aktiv zu unterstützen.
Was waren denn dann so Beispiele? Also was für Vorschläge hat man denn jetzt gemacht so? Ich meine das Problem ist, Leute können das nicht finanzieren oder fühlen sich nicht motiviert oder auch abgeschreckt davon, so eine energetische Sanierung oder zumindest Verbesserung durchzuführen, durchführen zu lassen. Was kann man denn dann der Politik raten?
Also wir haben die München-Studie, das ist eben so eine klassische Szenarienstudie gewesen, die man auch in München zur Kenntnis genommen hat und ich glaube auch dann den einen oder anderen Prozess dann mit inspiriert hat. Aber wo es eben nicht dazu kam, dass das jetzt sozusagen zu so einem systematischen Bauplan wurde. Und wir dann diese Studie zum Anlass genommen haben, etwas näher bei uns vor der Haustür im Ruhrgebiet auch anzugehen, mit einer ganzen Reihe Kooperationspartnern. Und zwar ist dort ein Wettbewerb entstanden, wo man eine Ruhrgebietsstadt gesucht hat, die sich selber zum Ziel setzte, innerhalb von nur 10 Jahren ihren CO2-Bedarf um 50% zu reduzieren. Also im Bestand, die Ruhrgebietsstädte die stehen ja auch alle dort und sagen, ja wir haben jetzt nicht nur die Ambition, uns mal so ein Konzept machen zu lassen, wie denn das gehen könnte, sondern wir wollen uns innerhalb von 10 Jahren gemeinsam auf den Weg machen.
Haben sich fast alle nordrheinwestfälischen, also Ruhrgebietsstädte beworben und den Zuschlag hat damals Bottrop bekommen. Bottrop so im Norden von Essen. Eine Stadt, die deswegen im Wettbewerb so überzeugt hat, weil dort damals der Oberbürgermeister und die gesamte Stadtverwaltung schon im Bewerbungsprozess die Bevölkerung ganz breit mitgenommen haben und sagen, das ist etwas, da wollen wir hin, das wollen wir auf den Weg bringen. Und dort nun seit ziemlich genau 5 Jahren, es ist jetzt Halbzeit, dann ein Prozess gestartet wurde in den verschiedenen Bereichen. Verkehr, aber insbesondere auch Gebäude, Energieversorgung, das anzugehen. Und wenn man jetzt zu dem Beispiel Gebäude zurückkommt und wie läuft das konkret? Dann stellt man fest, erstens konnten die Sanierungsraten erheblich erhöht werden, weil man eine ganz andere und sehr viel systematischere Beratung für die Hauseigentümer eingeführt hat.
Sich sehr schnell herausstellte, das zwar wahrnehmen, dass da was getan werden musst, aber dann oft erschlagen sind, von dem was dann diskutiert wird. Welcher Dämmstoff ist der richtige? Und führt das nicht dazu, dass dann innen alles schimmelt? Und sollt man nicht doch lieber auf eine andere Heizungsanlage setz? Oder ist die Solaranlage auf dem Dach extrem besser? Und alleine dieser Overload mit Informationen dann dazu führt, ach nee eh ich jetzt irgendwas falsches mache und auch Geld in die Hand nehme, lasse ich es lieber ganz. Und es sich da als extrem wertvoll erwiesen hat, dass dann die Stadt Bottrop mit Partnern entsprechende Beratungsstrukturen aufgebaut hat. Auch vor Ort die Eigentümer besucht hat. Und dann plötzlich so eine Netzwerkbewegung auch an gegenseitigem Vertrauen entstand, weil man sich an immer mehr Häusern von Nachbarn mal anschauen konnte wie das lief. Und sagt, hey das ist doch super, tolle Innenraumluft, hier schimmelt ja gar nichts, jetzt gehe ich das auch mal entsprechend an und lasse mich von denen beraten.
Dass heute Bottrop eine Sanierungsquote hat, die fast 7-10 mal so hoch liegt wie in den meisten anderen Städten. Und etwas was wir eben auch sehr sehr intensiv dann vorangetrieben haben, dass man eben nicht nur auf die technischen Möglichkeiten schaut, wie dämme ich anders oder wechsele aus, weil für viele der Haushalte ist das dann doch oft sehr teuer. Sondern auch berät, wie kann ich durch einfache Verhaltensänderung meinen Energieverbrauch schon erheblich runter fahren und damit nicht nur Geld sparen, sondern auch die CO2-Belastung reduzieren. Also das mal angepasst auch auf die ökonomischen Bedingungen einer solchen Stadt dann andere Lösungen findet.
Aber interessant finde ich natürlich jetzt vor allem, oder zumindest ist das jetzt gerade mal mein Blickwinkel, was sozusagen die politischen Empfehlungen sind. Weil man ja oft auch so den Eindruck hat, gut es mag Leute geben, die haben so einen Plan und die erzählen, wie man es eigentlich machen müsste, aber die Politik marschiert einfach geleitet aus einer anderen Informations- und Interessenpolitik einfach in eine andere Geschichte, solange bis man eben gegen die Wand läuft. Dann kann man sich natürlich immer hinstellen und sagen, naja wir haben es ja schon immer gesagt, aber das hilft ja dann eben auch irgendwie nicht so richtig. Das heißt die eigentliche Herausforderung insbesondere jetzt für die wissenschaftlich arbeitenden Menschen ist ja immer die Frage, wie kriege ich es vermittelt und was sind sagen wir mal gute Ansatzpunkte, um auch Gehör zu finden. Um sozusagen angenommen zu werden. Weil in dem Moment, wo man sagt, ja so Beratungsstelle wäre gut. Das alleine ist ja mal nur so ein Bulletpoint in einer längeren Liste.
Wie gestaltet sich sozusagen aus der Erfahrung der Prozess wie man diese Empfehlungen auch tatsächlich darreicht und letzten Endes auch umgesetzt bekommt?
Ich meine da sind wir eigentlich mittendrin, in dem was wir da so unter transformativer Wissenschaft haben. Denn Sie haben das ja gerade sehr schön beschrieben. So der Normalmodus von Wissenschaft ist eben oft, man entwickelt eine Lösung am grünen Tisch, sagt, das wäre eigentlich das perfekte politische Modell, arbeitet das im Detail aus und dann wirft man es über den Zaun zur Politik rüber. Und sagt, so das ist das was die Wissenschaft euch zu sagen hat, jetzt macht mal. Und da passiert nichts und die Wahrnehmung der Wissenschaft ist oft, naja gut, Politik da war ohnehin nichts zu erwarten. Jetzt haben wir denen so schön erklärt, wie es eigentlich geht und da draußen läuft gar nichts. Und diese ganze eigene Ignoranz und auch diese Wahrnehmung, das ist nicht unser Problem als Wissenschaft, sondern das ist das Problem da drüben, die es nicht richtig verstanden haben, das ist eben genau die Ursache, warum diese Wissenschaftspolitik und Wissenschaftsgesellschaftskommunikation oft so schlecht funktioniert.
Denn natürlich ist es auch Aufgabe und die Herausforderung von Wissenschaft, sehr genau zu verstehen, wo sind eigentlich die Akteure, die dann konkret gestalten müssen, unterwegs. Also in welchen Sachzwängen stecken die? Was sind die Kalküle und die Wahrnehmungsmuster, mit denen die legitimerweise aus der Logik ihres Handlungsfelds auf die Fragen schauen. Und das zusammenzubringen mit dem, was wir im Hinblick jetzt auf solche neuen Herausforderungen an Politikempfehlung gestalten. Und das kann nur funktionieren, wenn man schon ganz ganz früh im Prozess zusammensitzt und das auch zusammen denkt. Die Probleme schon gemeinsam so rahmt, dass auch derjenige, der später mit den Ergebnissen arbeiten muss, sagt, ja das ist jetzt wirklich eine richtig spannende Fragestellung, wenn wir sie so rahmen. Dann interessiert mich auch die Antwort. Wir haben ja heute das Problem, dass das Wissenschaftssystem in der Frage, was ist eine spannende Frage, sich nicht an denen da draußen orientiert, die konkrete Fragen haben und Gestaltungsanforderungen, sondern in der Regel an dem was der Wissenschaftlerkollege spannend findet.
Und der findet vielleicht spannende, dass in dem komplexen Modell, in dem man jetzt schon sieben schwierige Variablen kombinieren kann, noch eine achte kombinieren kann. Und dafür kriegst du dann deine wissenschaftliche Reputation, dafür kannst du publizieren, damit machst du deine wissenschaftliche Karriere. Den da draußen interessiert überhaupt nicht, ob das noch mit einer achten Variable geht, den interessiert es, wie man das so auf zwei Variablen reduzieren kann, dass er es auch seinem Wähler erklären kann und es trotzdem nicht falsch wird. Aber dafür gibt es keine wissenschaftlichen Lorbeeren und dadurch entsteht dann ganz ganz viel an wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen, das überhaupt nicht verarbeitet werden kann von den Akteuren da draußen. Und deswegen muss man, wenn man wie in dieser Debatte um Transdisziplinarität oder transformative Wissenschaft diskutiert wird, sozial robustes Wissen erzeugen will. Also ein Wissen, das nicht nur wissenschaftlich anschlussfähig ist, das muss es natürlich auch sein. Sondern dass es auch eine Orientierung gibt für die Akteure, muss man die Fragestellung schon gemeinsam entwickeln. Muss auf das, was an gewaltigen Wissensvorräten bei den Akteuren vor Ort da ist, in Hinblick auf Gestaltung.
Denn so ein Oberbürgermeister der hat ein sehr gutes Gefühl dafür, was er seiner Stadt zumuten kann, wie er die Menschen erreicht. Das ist ja ganz zentrales Wissen, wenn ich Veränderungsprozesse gestalten will. Das muss in die Art und Weise der Wissensproduktion auch von Wissenschaft mit einfließen. Erst dann kommt da was raus, was wirklich eine Orientierungsfunktion hat.
Heißt das, dass die Wissenschaft sozusagen das falsche Belohnungsmodell hat an der Stelle und bestimmte Ziele als noch nicht erstrebenswert ansieht oder bestimmte Motivationsmuster einfach nicht daraus ziehen kann, sich in die richtige Richtung zu entwickeln?
Absolut. Also die Logik und die macht ja durchaus aus zu einem gewissen Grad sind, von Wissenschaft ist ja, Komplexität dadurch in den Griff zu bekommen, indem ich mich auf einzelne Facetten konzentriere und die dann in der Tiefe verstehe. Das ist ja auch die Logik, warum sich eine Hochschule in Disziplinen organisiert, damit mache ich diese ganze komplexe Welt überhaupt handhabbar und kann dann mit einer Tiefenbohrung eben zum Beispiel einen ökonomischen Mechanismus oder eine ganz bestimmte naturwissenschaftlichen Teilprozess im Detail verstehen. Und das ist auch entscheidend für den Erkenntnisfortschritt. Aber man muss immer wieder sehen, wenn ich das jetzt in eine reale Welt zurückspiele, die ja komplex ist, wo die Dinge miteinander vernetzt sind, muss ich einen Weg finden, um diese unterschiedlichen Erkenntnisse, die aus den disziplinären Tiefbohrungen kommen, wieder neu aufeinander zu beziehen. Und das passiert im Wissenschaftssystem an viel zu wenig Orten.
Also wir brauchen, und dafür gibt es eben kaum Belohnungen, solche Wissensintegrationsorte. Und Wuppertal-Institut und einige andere Institutionen sind solche Orte, aber die spielen im Gesamtsystem eben eher eine völlig noch untergeordnete Rolle vor dem Hintergrund eigentlich der vielen Wissensvorräte, die im Wissenschaftssystem da sind und die wir auch bräuchten für die großen Herausforderungen, mit denen wir umzugehen haben. Also insofern ist das Anreizsystem im Wissenschaftssystem einfach zu einseitig, nur auf eine ganz bestimmte Form von Wissensproduktion gerichtet. Und es gibt zu wenig Anreize, dass auch dieser Typus Wissensintegratorenintegrator im System bleibt und es Orte existieren, in denen das passiert.
Und ist die Frage, ob das allein nur mit den richtigen Belohnungen sich schon einsortiert. Ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht nehme ich auch einen leichten Kulturwandel wahr, gerade jetzt hier im letzten Gespräch mit Klaus Kümmerer, wo es um Nachhaltigkeit und Wasser geht. Der Erfolg seines Instituts in diesem Bereich basiert ja auch genau auf dieser breiten Aufstellung und der Interdisziplinarität am Institut. Dass man halt einfach gesagt hat, man kann jetzt hier nicht nur mit Chemikern sozusagen da hier die Wahrheit finden und medizinische Aspekte berücksichtigen, sondern muss im Prinzip das vollkommene Wissen darüber haben, was halt bis in philosophische Fragen reingeht. Und was einem glaube ich dann auch in der Folge, wenn ich ihn richtig interpretiert habe, auch in zunehmendem Maße dann auch ermächtigt hat, dann eben auch viel politischer zu sprechen, im Sinne von breiter abwägend, mehr Aspekte sehen.
Was ja dann in der Regel wahrscheinlich immer das Gegenargument der Politik ist, ja da mögt ihr ja recht haben, aber hier die Müllabfuhr da, diese Zwänge und so weiter, volkswirtschaftlicher Nutzen blablabla. Das sind ja sozusagen dann auch Argumente, die dann einfach benötigt werden. Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass eine interdisziplinäre Orientierung eines Instituts, Forschungsbereich oder Fakultät an der Universität helfen kann. Ist das sagen wir mal an sich schon mal so ein Trend, der da ist oder da sein sollte? Hilft das allein schon und was braucht man vielleicht noch?
Ja man muss sehen, und insofern ist Klaus Kümmerer ein sehr schönes Beispiel, was Klau Kümmerer dort beschreibt und auch die Situation, in der er sich befindet, immer noch eine ziemliche Ausnahmesituation in der deutschen Hochschul- und Universitätslandschaft ist. Also Klaus Kümmerer ist ja auch der Leuphaner Universität in Lüneburg und das ist ja die erste Universität, die es gewagt hat, eine interdisziplinäre Fakultät für Nachhaltigkeitswissenschaft zu gründen. Also wo dann eben Chemiker zusammenarbeiten. Nicht nur mit Biologen und Mathematikern, sondern eben auch mit Sozialwissenschaftlern, Ökonomen und Ethikern. Und dadurch dieser integrierte Blick, den Sie gerade geschildert haben, der möglich wird. Und in der Regel finden Sie so etwas an kaum einer anderen Universität. Also insbesondere auch den Mut, die Fakultätsstrukturen in so einer Form aufzulösen.
Weil wenn Sie promovieren wollen, müssen Sie sich entscheiden, welcher Disziplin gehöre ich an. Und da wagen sich auch ganz wenige Chemieprofessorinnen und -professoren in solche neuen Strukturen, sondern da will man in einem Fachbereich in der Fakultät für Chemie sein. Und wenn dann jemand kommt, der so eine Doppelqualifikation hat, vielleicht einen Bachelor in Chemie und dann einen Master in Sozialwissenschaften gemacht, der hat richtig große Probleme, dann irgendwo an einer Fakultät angenommen zu werden. Die sagen, der ist doch kein Chemiker, passt bei uns nicht wirklich. Und da sind dann solche Orte, wie sie jetzt in Lüneburg entstanden sind, die wenigen existierenden Inseln. Aber Sie haben absolut recht, genau diese Struktursprünge, die braucht es, aber da kommt erst ganz langsam Bewegung ins System.
Ja da sind wir ja dann vor allem nicht nur an der Frage, wie bedient man die Politik, sondern hier ist es ja vor allem eine Frage der Bildungspolitik.
Ja absolut. Der Bildungs- und der Wissenschaftspolitik. Und da ist ja auch eine große Debatte im Gange. Wie stark sollte sich Politik eigentlich auch einmischen, um so eine Weiterentwicklung des Wissenschaftssystems zu befördern? Und es ja seit so den 00er Jahren eher die Tendenz gab der Wissenschaft und auch den Hochschulen, ein gewaltiges Maß an Autonomie einzuräumen und ihnen eben Geld zuzusichern und dann auch entsprechend machen zu lassen. Und im Hinblick auf diesen Umgang und die Beziehung zu diesen gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen, das schaffen auch solche interdisziplinären Strukturen. Muss man eben sagen, dass diese Selbstorganisation nur sehr bedingt gewirkt hat. Weil es natürlich so ist, dass die wissenschaftlichen Karrieren heute eher nach disziplinärer Logik vergeben werden.
Und daher sich diejenigen, die über so eine Logik in ihr Professoramt gekommen sind und jetzt wieder den Nachwuchs ausbilden, dann sich sehr schwer tun, einzugestehen, dass es hier eine Bewegung in sehr viel inter- und transdisziplinäre Strukturen braucht. Und daher reproduziert sich das System auch immer wieder selber. Und ich glaube ohne auch intelligente wissenschaftspolitische Impulse, die ja dann nicht die Forschung und Wissenschaft in Frage stellen, aber nochmal andere Anreize und Bedingungen dafür schaffen, dass sich auch so eine kritische Masse dann an wirklich inter- und transdisziplinär arbeitenden Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern herausbildet, wird es vermutlich nicht gehen. Und deswegen gibt es ja auch so eine intensive Diskussion derzeit über.
Das heißt im Prinzip setzt das Annehmen der neuen Herausforderungen, wenn ich sie jetzt mal richtig deute, also insbesondere jetzt im Kontext der Nachhaltigkeit, was sich ja auf sehr sehr viele Bereiche, wen nicht fast alles, bezieht, setzt auch eine andere strukturelle Arbeit voraus. Die Sie im Wuppertal-Institut in gewisser Hinsicht selber versuchen im Rahmen der Studienarbeit. Aber was wir jetzt hier zumindest in Ausrissen auch schon an anderen Stellen finden und was ja auch ganz interessante Ergebnisse erzielt, aber letzten Endes ist es etwas, was so aus dem systemischen heraus sich eigentlich entwickeln müsste. Wo man sagt, man muss jetzt quasi anfangen, das Lernen und frühe wissenschaftliche Arbeiten oder das Erlernen des wissenschaftlichen Arbeitens im Prinzip schon frühzeitig mit solchen Strukturveränderungen zu begegnen.
Damit es dann später sozusagen, jetzt habe ich 15 Jahre studiert, jetzt muss ich alles anders machen, funktioniert ja jetzt auch nicht bei jedem. Sondern wenn man im Prinzip sagt, jetzt habe ich schon 10 Jahre lang hier so ganz anders gearbeitet, jetzt muss ich das hier irgendwie auch in die reale Welt einfügen. Wie kann man da auf Universitäten, Hochschulen, andere Bildungseinrichtungen zugehen und inwiefern machen Sie das vielleicht auch schon? Was sind da sozusagen die Angebote, die Vorschläge an die Bildungseinrichtungen?
Also ich glaube einmal ist nochmal ganz wichtig zu betonen, das was Sie gerade klar gemacht haben, dass es hier wirklich um institutionelle und strukturelle Veränderungen geht. Und das stößt erst mal auf einen gewaltigen Widerstand.
Weil Änderung, gefährlich.
Weil Änderung ja, und insbesondere auf die Organisationsstrukturen. Viele, gerade in Hochschulen, haben immer das Gefühl, Universitäten gibt es in einer ähnlichen Form schon seit 500 Jahren. Auch wenn man sich anschaut, welche Institutionen, die heute noch existieren, gab es schon vor 500 Jahren. Sind glaube ich von den 100 Institutionen, von denen das der Fall ist, ist irgendwie das britische Parlament mit dabei und dann sind es aber ansonsten nur noch Universitäten. Und so das Gefühl, so ein bisschen fast wie katholische Kirche, das lief immer schon so, das muss auch künftig so laufen, das kann man sich gar nicht anders vorstellen, dass man Universität anders organisieren kann.
Ja das Krokodil sah ja zu Zeiten der Dinosaurier auch schon so aus.
Und das ist ja eine Debatte, die uns nicht nur im Hinblick auf diese Nachhaltigkeit verfolgt, sondern auch auf Digitalisierung. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wie schwerfällig die Universitäten auf die Herausforderung dessen was mit Digitalisierung passiert reagiert, hat man ja die gleiche Reaktion. So nach dem Motto, das hat doch nichts mit uns zu tun. Aber dass hier sich die DNA von Wissensgesellschaften komplett neu konfiguriert und dass natürlich ganz ganz viel mit den Schlüsselwissensinstitutionen in so einer Gesellschaft zu tun, das wird zum großen Teil ausgeblendet. Und führt eben dazu, dass gerade wenn man über Dinosaurier spricht, die zentralen Wissensorte, die Impulsgeber, die Inspirationsorte in diesem 21. Jahrhundert, nämlich Hochschulen die es eigentlich sein müssten, sich zunehmend zu Dinosaurier entwickeln. Also weder für die Fragen der Digitalisierung noch für die Fragen dieser kommenden Nachhaltigkeitsherausforderung wirklich die Orte sind, die die Impulse geben. Sondern es verlagert inzwischen an komplett andere Orte Insbesondere wenn sich da strukturell nichts verändert.
Was heißt das nun konkret? Also um was für Formen von strukturellen Änderungen geht es? Das eine, das sprachen wir gerade an, ist das was sich in Universitäten tun muss. Also mehr Orte zu schaffen, wo dieser interdisziplinäre Bezug, aber auch die frühe Zusammenarbeit mit Akteuren außerhalb des Wissenschaftssystems zur Regel wird. Das gilt in der Forschung, aber das gilt eben auch ganz früh in der Lehre. Also Studierende sollen natürlich eine disziplinäre Identität entwickeln. Sollen verstehen, warum jetzt meine spezifische Tiefbohrung, die ich ja als Chemiker oder als Soziologin vornehme, warum mir das nochmal einen ganz eigenen vertieften Blick auf die Welt ermöglicht. Aber dieser vertiefte Blick muss schon früh konfrontiert werden mit dem Blick anderer Disziplinen. Indem ich verstehe, was kann ich eigentlich als Chemikerin und Chemiker besonders gut verstehen und was muss ich aber dafür ausblenden?
Und warum ist der Blick des Soziologen so wichtig und hilft mir, wenn es drum geht, die Bedeutung und die Nutzung von Chemikalien, wenn sie dann weltweit eingesetzt werden mit ihren Nebenfolgen, besser einzuordnen, wenn ich mich früh schon mit einer Soziologin, Soziologen unterhalte. Und das gleichzeitig immer wieder in Beziehung zu setzen zu realen Prozessen dort draußen. Und diese Form des problembasierten Lernens, dessen was wir zum Teil ja auch in den 70er/80er Jahren sehr intensiv in Form des Projektstudiums hatten, das führt dann letztlich auch zu einer sehr viel ganzheitlicheren und integrierten intellektuellen Entwicklung von jungen Menschen, die sich dann in einer solchen Welt orientieren müssen und macht sie letztlich dann auch zu besseren Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern. Gibt ja diesen schönen Spruch, wer nur Chemie versteht, der versteht auch davon nichts. Das gilt eben auch für jede andere Disziplin. Und diese Form der Kontextualisierung die wird an Bedeutung gewinnen. Und dafür muss ich in den Universitäten, in der Lehre, aber auch in der Forschung Strukturen, Studiengänge, Zentren, aber eben auch ganze interdisziplinäre Fakultäten wie in Lüneburg schaffen.
Dann ist es wichtig, dass die Orte, wo diese Form von transdisziplinärem Vorgehens und Forschung praktiziert werden, dass die noch intensiver vernetzt werden mit dem restlichen Wissenschaftssystem. Das Wuppertal-Institut oder es gibt eine ganze Reihe solcher Pionier-Institute, die oft so in den 80/90er Jahren entstanden sind. Das Öko-Institut in Freiburg. Das Institut für ökologische Wirtschaftsforschung in Berlin oder das Institut für sozialökologische Forschung in Frankfurt, das sind eigentlich solche Orte, die genau diese Form transdisziplinärer Wissenschaft im System etabliert haben. Die aber weil sie eben keinerlei – also bei uns, wir sind ja vom Land NRW grundfinanziert und wir haben da insofern eine komfortable Ausgangssituation, - aber viele andere der Vorreiterinstitute kriegen überhaupt keine öffentliche Förderung, die leben nur von Drittmitteln. Was sie auch agil hält auf der einen Seite, aber was es eben verhindert, dass dieses Wissen, solche Wissensintegration herbeizuführen, Kapazitäten dafür da sind, sich mit dem etablierten System noch anders zu vernetzen.
Also da Orte und Netzwerkinstitutionen zu schaffen, die einfach dazu beitragen, dass das KnowHow, das eigentlich im System ist, noch stärker fruchtbar gemacht wird. Und ein dritter wichtiger Ansatz, und da ist in den letzten Jahren einiges in Bewegung gekommen, um diese Form der Wissensintegration zu praktizieren, braucht es auch zum Teil ganz neue Formen von wissenschaftlichen Infrastrukturen. Also was meine ich damit? Wir diskutieren sehr intensiv derzeit über Reallabore. Ich habe das Bottrop-Beispiel.
Entschuldigung, Real?
Reallabore. Und ich will das an einem Beispiel deutlich machen. Ich habe ja gerade über diesen Fall Bottrop gesprochen. Also wie schaffe ich das eigentlich, dass so eine Stadt innerhalb von 10 Jahren ihren CO2-Bedarf um 50% reduziert? Und das ist ja ein Mix aus intelligenten Technologien, pfiffigen Geschäftsmodellen, Verhaltensveränderungen, intelligenten Formen politischer Anreize. Da kommen also ganz ganz viele Komponenten zusammen und das hat eine Komplexität, die kann man nicht nur am Schreibtisch modellieren. Da muss man ähnlich wie jemand, der eine komplexe Maschine baut, da muss man eine Kultur des Experimentierens schaffen. Muss man Räume schaffen, in denen man mit den Akteuren vor Ort und das muss mit denen ja auf einer Augenhöhe auch ausgehandelt werden, man Dinge ausprobiert, experimentiert, das begleitet, schaut, was funktioniert, was funktioniert nicht. Was heißt das jetzt dann für eine Weiterentwicklung? Wie kann ich Dinge, die ich in einer Stadt lerne, auf andere übertragen?
Und diese Idee, sozusagen den Laborbegriff, der sich in den Naturwissenschaften und Technikwissenschaften längst bewährt hat als ein Ort, der dazu beiträgt, neues Wissen zu generieren, nun zu übertragen auf solche gesellschaftlichen und ökonomischen Transformationsorte. Und das Land Baden-Württemberg hat zum Beispiel vor drei Jahren eine ganze Förderlinie solcher Reallabore ausgeschrieben. Da sind jetzt eine ganze Reihe an Städten, an Stadtquartieren, ein ganzer Naturpark hier im Nordschwarzwald sind jetzt zu solchen Laboren definiert worden, in denen die Akteure vor Ort mit Wissenschaftseinrichtungen sich auf den Weg dieses Experimentierens machen. Und solche Infrastrukturen, in denen Wissenschaft mit Akteuren zusammenarbeiten und ganz konkrete Veränderungsprozesse ausprobieren kann ist zum Beispiel auch so eine ganz wichtige institutionelle strukturelle Reform.
Und so wie wir in den 60/70er Jahren große Forschungsreaktoren aufgebaut haben, um die Atomforschung voranzutreiben, so brauchen wir in einer Zeit, wo es eben nicht mehr nur um isolierte technologische Innovationen geht, sondern die Mischung von technologischen, sozialen, ökonomischen Veränderungen, brauchen wir sozusagen neue Experimentierorte und die müssen aber auch ein wichtiger Teil dann der Forschungspolitik mit werden.
Und der Ausbildung sozusagen?
Und der Ausbildung. Genau, denn da kann ich natürlich, und wir machen das in Wuppertal natürlich auch vor Ort, wo wir ganz viel solcher Laborsituationen in der Stadt Wuppertal schaffen, wo wir dann mit unseren Studierenden rausgehen und sagen, guck mal hier, das ist eine hochinteressante Initiative, die jetzt alternativen Fahrradverkehr versucht, in Wuppertal voranzutreiben. Jetzt entwickeln wir mit denen doch mal gemeinsame Organisations- und Geschäftsmodelle. Versuchen Kommunikationskampagnen zu konzipieren, mit denen wir die Bevölkerung überzeugen und dann ist das gleichzeitig auch ein hochinteressanter Lernort für die Studierenden. Wo die wissen, dass sie Wissen aus ihren Disziplinen mitbringen dann auf einen solchen konkreten Anwendungsort beziehen können.
Interessant finde ich in dem Zusammenhang auch die Erwähnung von Geschäftsmodell, dass das ja sozusagen dann eben auch diese wirtschaftliche Komponente eigentlich zwangsläufig mit beinhalten muss, weil es ja einfach Teil der Gesamtrechnung ist in dem Moment, wo man eben versucht, interdisziplinär und nachhaltig draufzuschauen, heißt das ja, das muss sich letzten Endes auch in unserem wirtschaftlichen System verankern können. Das muss dort einen Platz haben. Das muss dort die Möglichkeit geben, entsprechende Branchen auszubilden, die selber wiederum die entsprechenden Startbedingungen auch vorfinden müssen, um arbeiten zu können. In einem vielleicht zunächst einmal defizitären Bereich. Ich meine, man hat das ja bei der Solarindustrie auch gesehen. Das wäre dann sozusagen auch nochmal so ein weiterer Aspekt, der da noch mit reinkommt, abgesehen von dieser politischen Dimension.
Wichtige Komponente. Ich meine, dadurch dass ich natürlich selber dann in der Universität Wuppertal dann auch einen wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen Studiengang mitbetreue ist das natürlich ein Aspekt, der mich dann auch mal wieder interessiert. Wichtig ist dann aber gleichzeitig, dass man es eben nicht auf das nur ökonomisch funktionierende reduziert. Sondern dass man bei solchen Projekten auch schaut, wenn wir das jetzt nur in Geschäftsmodellen denken, die aufgehen, wozu führt denn das eigentlich in so einem Quartier? Also wir haben gerade wenn wir über so einen Quartierswandel nachdenkt, dann wissen wir ja aus Städten wie Berlin, dass da viele Dinge funktionieren, aber am Ende ein komplett durchgentrifizierter Stadtteil entsteht. Und dann früh zu sehen, na gut jetzt müssen wir aber auch politisch so Rahmenbedingungen setzen, dass sich tragfähige Geschäftsmodelle entwickeln können, aber die immer wieder im Blick, dass eben nicht alles da komplett durchökonomisiert wird. Also sagen, dass das plötzlich hipp ist, dass das ein nachhaltiger Stadtteil ist, aber am Ende nur noch eine ganz homogene andere Bevölkerung da drin lebt und eine Vielfalt des Stadtteils darunter auch verloren geht.
Darum ist dann auch bei solchen Projekten wichtig, dass ein Wirtschaftswissenschaftler früh mit einer Soziologin/einem Soziologen zusammenarbeitet, um um solche sozialen Dynamiken weiß und man gemeinsam dann eben überlegt, wie muss ich das integriert angehen, dass da am Ende wirklich höhere Lebensqualität und eine interessante Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie bei rauskommt.
Ich finde das ganz lustig, weil wir ja eigentlich so, wenn man das alte Wissenschaftlerbild von vor 200-300 Jahren herbeinimmt, da haben wir sozusagen das Ideal des Universalgelehrten, der man ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon sein musste, mangels der teilweise also überhaupt der fachspezifischen Ausprägung beziehungsweise überhaupt des Nichtvorhandenseins dieses Begriffs Wissenschaft als solcher. Und dann haben wir halt die Leonardo Da Vincis, die Goethes etc., die alle sich irgendwie mit unterschiedlichen Schwerpunkten, vielleicht aus heutiger Sicht mehr in einem Fachbereich, verorten lassen. Aber die am Ende vor allem dadurch zu ihren Leistungen gekommen sind, weil sie sich eben sehr breit aufgestellt haben. Eben in gewisser Hinsicht auch interdisziplinär haben arbeiten müssen. Die hohe Spezialisierung der letzten 100  Jahre hatte ja auch ihr gutes, weil es ja einfach auch eine enorme Beschleunigung erzeugt hat auf allen nur denkbaren Ebenen.
Nur jetzt haben wir sozusagen so den Teufel, den wir riefen im Haus, dass das einfach die wirtschaftliche, industrielle Entwicklung und natürlich auch die Bevölkerungsentwicklung der Menschheit insgesamt jetzt einfach so viel Stress auf diesem Planeten und damit auch unsere Gesellschaft wieder zurückbringt, das wir jetzt eigentlich mal drosseln müssen und gucken müssen, ob nicht sozusagen dieser Universalansatz jetzt auch hilfreich sein kann. Heißt das, dass man sozusagen weggeht vom, naja ich studiere X und vielleicht habe ich noch so ein Nebenfach in .... hin zu, bevor man nicht irgendwie drei verschiedene, vollkommen disjunkte Felder sich angeschaut, darf man sich gar nicht erst richtig Wissenschaftler nennen. Ist natürlich auch ein bisschen überzogen. Weil man braucht ja auch die Spezialisten.
Aber Sie haben die Dialektik sehr gut beschrieben. Also sozusagen dieses aus dem Universalgelehrten kommen und dann diese gewaltige Dynamik, die die Spezialisierung ausgelöst hat und jetzt ist eben die Frage, wie kriege ich das in ein neues Gleichgewicht? Also wie erhalte ich mir eigentlich diese kreative und innovative Dynamik der Spezialisierung und führe doch dann auch wieder solche Rückbindungsmechanismen ins System ein.
Und diese Rückbindung, die wird angesichts der Komplexität, die heute Wissen hat, nicht darin bestehen, wieder nur noch reine Universalgelehrte einzuführen, sondern diese Rückbindungsmechanismen, die brauchen sicher einmal möglichst eine kritische Menge an Akteurinnen und Akteuren in dem Wissenschaftssystem, die neben ihrer Spezialkompetenz auch ein Gefühl dafür haben, wie eigentlich Andockstellen und Integrationsmöglichkeiten zu anderen Feldern da sind. Also da muss eine kritische Masse da sein. Die wird heute eben nicht in der ausreichenden Zahl ausgebildet und kann sich im Forschungssystem entwickeln.
Also Personen, die neben dem Spezialwissen auch ein Gefühl dafür haben, wie diese Andockungen aussehen. Und es braucht eben sagen wir mal Formen institutionalisierter und virtualisierter Universalgelehrter. Und das können dann Institutionen sein, also Institute wie unsere und andere, die durch ihre sehr interdisziplinäre Zusammensetzung solche Andockpunkte schaffen. Und dann eben Orte, in denen sich – ich habe diese Reallabore angesprochen – in denen dieses unterschiedliche Wissen in einer Form zusammenkommen muss, damit sich dann dort vor Ort auch was zum Guten ändert. Und dann hat man ja so einen außerwissenschaftlichen Maßstab und kann beurteilen, funktioniert das oder nicht. Ich finde das veranschauliche ich mir immer ganz gerne so an der Robotik. Da gibt es ja diese Fußballcups der Roboter.
Robocup.
Und dieser Robocup ist eben ein wunderschönes Beispiel auch dafür, wie gut interdisziplinäre Zusammenarbeit funktionieren kann, weil allen klar ist, am Ende geht es darum, dass unser Roboter und unser Roboteam da auf dem Spielfeld gewinnt und plötzlich hast du eine Kooperationsdynamik zwischen Informatikern, Ingenieuren, Kognitionswissenschaftlern, weil die ständig analysieren, mann, warum haben wir schon wieder 0:7 verloren, was konnte unser Roboter da nicht. Und das nennt man in der Forschung über Transdisziplinarität ein sogenanntes Boundary Object. Also so ein Objekt, in dem die unterschiedlichen Wissensbereiche sich aufeinander beziehen müssen. Und du hast ein außerwissenschaftliches Kriterium, ob das gut gelungen ist oder nicht. Nämlich in dem Fall, ob dein Roboteam da gewinnt oder nicht. Und ähnlich ist das mit diesen Reallaboren. Du kannst nach 10 Jahren schauen, hat das in Bottrop geklappt mit den 50% CO2-Reduktion oder hat es nicht geklappt? Und was ist da eigentlich schief gelaufen? Waren die Technologien nicht richtig, hat man nicht die richtigen Geschäftsmodelle, haben wir gewisse soziale und Konsumentendynamiken übersehen?
Und auf die Weise findet dann eben so ein gemeinsames Lernen statt. Und das ist eben etwas, worüber dann auch so eine Integration passieren kann. Also ich brauche sozusagen institutionalisierte Universalgelehrte, aber das sind dann nicht mehr einzelne Personen, sondern das sind Formen und Orte, in denen die individuellen und hochausdifferenzierten Wissensbestände in einer ganzheitlichen Form aufeinander bezogen werden.
Jetzt kann man ja auch nicht sagen, dass es das alles überhaupt gar nicht gäbe. Also wenn man sich gerade auch im Förderbereich die Programme der EU anschaut, Horizont2020, alle Fördermodelle basieren ja im Prinzip auch schon auf einer relativ starken Interdisziplinarität, naja will jetzt nicht das ein bisschen überschätzen, aber vor allem ist man halt gezwungen, sich ja länderübergreifend mit vielen Teams zusammenzusetzen, wo so eine gewisse Interdisziplinarität natürlich automatisch dazukommt, weil man ja nicht immer nur nochmal vom selben Wissen mehr braucht, sondern das eben auch breit aufstellen möchte. Und es gibt natürlich auch die Stiftungslandschaft, sollte man auch vielleicht nochmal erwähnen, die ja auch gerade im Hinblick auf diese Vernetzung der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit durchaus auch eine Rolle spielt. Ist das so das, was Sie sich als Vernetzung des Wissenschaftssystems vorstellen oder was hatten Sie da so im Hinterkopf, als Sie diesen zweiten Punkt genannt hatten?
Ja also Sie haben absolut recht, es gibt eine ganze Reihe an Ansätzen, aber wenn man sich das jetzt in den Größenordnungen anschaut, sind das eben immer homöopathische Dosen, in denen es das gibt. Denn auch in der Stiftungslandschaft sind da einige Stiftungen durchaus sehr innovativ unterwegs. Aber wenn man das in Beziehung setzt jetzt zu den rund 30-40 Milliarden Euro, die insgesamt allein im Hochschulsystem dann stecken, sind das eben letztlich so Tropfen auf den heißen Stein. Und das ist deswegen schade, weil damit eben auch ganz ganz viele dieser disziplinären Wissensbestände, die eigentlich da wären und die wir ja auch bräuchten, um noch sehr viel differenzierter und intelligenter über diese großen Herausforderungen von diesen Ökologie- und Nachhaltigkeitsfragen, so was wie Flüchtlingsthematik nehmen, die Digitalisierung, die wir eigentlich noch stärker bräuchten, um als Gesellschaft intelligent darüber zu diskutieren, nicht wirklich in Wert gesetzt werden.
Und es ist durchaus aber interessant zu schauen, wo funktioniert das? Und es funktioniert dort, und auch zum Teil sehr sehr gut, wo unmittelbare wirtschaftliche Verwertungsfähigkeit da ist. Also wenn man sich anschaut, die Ingenieurwissenschaften, die können heute hochinterdisziplinär zusammenarbeiten, wenn es darum geht, einen Automotor zu verbessern. Oder die internetbasierte Steuerung von Automobilen voranzutreiben. Oder ein wunderbares Beispiel auch die Medizin. Das ist ja unglaublich die ganze medizinische Forschung, die dann in der Behandlung von Krankheitsbildern gewaltig vorangegangen ist, weil da natürlich auch gewaltige Märkte dahinterstecken. Das heißt diese ökonomisch verwertbaren Bereiche zeigen, welche Wissensintegration eigentlich geht, aber haben eben das große Problem, dass sich das eben auch nur auf das ökonomisch verwertbare konzentriert.
Wir haben ja diese Debatte im Gesundheitssystem immer dann wenn es um Krankheitsbilder geht, die nicht für die westliche Welt relevant sind, sondern für Länder, in denen es kaum Zahlungsbereitschaften gibt, wo dann kaum weder die universitäre noch die Pharmaindustrieforschung ein Interesse hat, da sehr viel zu machen. Und dann kommt noch was anderes hinzu, bei dem was wir da medizinisch möglich machen durch herausragende Forschung, oft gar nicht mit bedenken, welche ökonomischen gesellschaftlichen Folgen hat denn das? Also wir haben diese Debatte ja derzeit um diese hochkomplexen Krebstherapien, mit denen es dann gelingt, ein Leben auch nochmal um 6 Monate oder ein Jahr zu verlängern, aber die dann Behandlungskosten in Höhe von 100.000 Euro mehr pro Jahr erzeugen und unsere öffentlich finanzierten und solidarisch finanzierten Gesundheitssysteme an die Grenzen treiben. Also die Dynamik wie viel individualisierten technologischen Fortschritt können wir uns eigentlich in einem solidarisch organisierten Gesundheitssystem erlauben?
Das früh auch gemeinsam zu diskutieren, aufeinander zu beziehen, das passiert dann eben kaum. Und das ist sozusagen der nächste Schritt, die nächste Dimension auch der Bezugnahme, die es braucht. Also insofern ja, es ist einiges unterwegs, aber eine wirklich umfassende und auch breit verstandene Transdisziplinarität mit so einem gesellschaftlichen Kompass steht an vielen Stellen noch aus.
Jetzt fiel das ja schon paar mal der Begriff der Digitalisierung, war ja hier auch schon ein paar mal ein Thema, insbesondere was so die Herausforderung für die Lehre betrifft. Haben Sie sich jetzt im Rahmen der Institutsarbeit oder aus anderen Überlegungen heraus da schon etwas konkreter mit befasst, was hier die sozusagen das Problem ist gerade, woran es mangelt?
Also ich meine das hat jetzt ja im Hinblick jetzt auf unser Thema so zwei grundsätzliche Dimensionen. Einmal ist ja die Frage, was bedeutet eigentlich dieser Prozess der Digitalisierung für diese ganzen Herausforderungen nachhaltiger Entwicklung? Und das ist ja extrem vielfältig, das reicht von der ganzen Frage. Welche Potenziale zur Steigerung von Energie- und Ressourceneffizienz stecken dahinter. Was macht das mit unseren globalen Wertschöpfungsstrukturen? Können wir wieder in ganz neuer Form regionalisieren, wenn wir an FabLabs oder ähnliches denken oder werden die globalisierten Wertschöpfungsketten nochmal vorangetrieben? Dann kriegen wir langsam ein Gefühl dafür, dass diese vermeintlich so immaterielle Form der Wirtschaft einen gewaltigen ökologischen Rucksack hat. Die Energieverbräuche der Rechenzentren. Sagen, das was früher einmal ein Blick auf den Fahrplan war ist heute eine 50fache iPhone-Abfrage während des Zugs und generiert das jedes Mal Energieverbrauch.
Das was an Ressourcen Rucksäcken in all diesen dann oft nur zwei Jahre genutzten Mobilgeräten steckt. Also da kommt ja ein gewaltiger ökologischer Rucksack auf uns zu. Bis hin zu Fragen in der Organisation neuer Formen, globaler Solidarität, das Aushandeln dieser Prozesse, sind die Vernetzungsmöglichkeiten da eher eine Chance oder ist das sozusagen die Plattform für die durchkommerzialisierte Volksverdummung. Also auf ganz ganz vielen Ebenen hängen diese Prozesse der Digitalisierung mit Herausforderungen und Nachhalt der Entwicklung zusammen. Und da muss man auch sagen, da ist die Nachhaltigkeitscommunity noch ganz am Anfang. Also das muss man sich auch sozusagen an den eigenen Bart fassen, dass im Hinblick auf die Frage, was heißt das eigentlich für die Herausforderungen nachhaltiger Entwicklung? Wir bisher ja erst einzelne Facetten des Gesamtbildes haben und das ist eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe in den nächsten Jahren, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Weil das ist einer Megatrends der Gesellschaften und Ökonomien umgestalten wird. Und wenn wir angemessen über nachhaltige Entwicklung nachdenken, müssen wir viel viel besser auch als Nachhaltigkeitsinstitute verstehen, wie das zusammenhängt. Und die zweite Dimension ist ja die Frage, was heißt Digitalisierung, die Möglichkeiten von Digitalisierung für diese neuen Formen der Wissensproduktion? Also wie kann ich das eigentlich nutzen, diese Form verteilter und leichter verfügbarer Intelligenz, um dann solche Arten integrierten Wissens zu erzeugen. Und auch dort kriegt man ja so erste Ahnungen, die derzeit sehr intensiv diskutiert werden, unter so einem Stichwort Citizen Science und Bürgerwissenschaften. Und das was da in dem Spektrum läuft hat eben auch eine sehr weite Reichweite.
Da geht es einmal darum, bestehende Daten, dadurch dass ganz viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich beteiligen, systematisch ja überhaupt erfassen und auswerten zu können. Und das ist natürlich einmal interessant, wenn an jetzt Sternenlandkarten auswertet, aber ist natürlich auch relevant, um zum Beispiel ein Monitoring von Ökosystemen zu machen. Also wir feststellen, dass bestimmte Insektenarten zunehmend verschwinden und wir gar nicht richtig verstehen können womit das zusammenhängt. Und wenn Sie die Bürgerinnen und Bürger, die sich regelmäßig in der Natur bewegen, die interessiert sind an diesen Zusammenhängen einsetzen sozusagen als breit verteilte Sensoren, können Sie solche Veränderungen im Biosystem sehr sehr viel früher dann auch abbilden. Wir haben natürlich durch das, was jetzt an Datenerfassung passiert, über die gesamten mobilen Devices, die Bewegungsmuster schaffe ich natürlich gewaltige Datengrundlagen, um zum Beispiel in solchen Reallaboren zu verstehen, wenn ich gewisse Interventionen mache, führt das wirklich zu nachhaltigerem Verkehrsverhalten?
Wie finden denn wirklich die Anpassungen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger statt? Bis hin, das ist ein Thema, das uns jetzt in Wuppertal sehr stark beschäftigt, Zufriedenheitsmonitoring. Also zu sehen, wie sind Lebensqualitätswahrnehmungen eigentlich in Stadtvierteln und wie verändern die sich, wenn ich jüber eine nachhaltige Stadtentwicklung dort eingreife? Führt das wirklich zu den erwarteten Effekten? Wo entstehen bestimmte Formen von Unzufriedenheit und Widerständen? Also auch für diese Form der Transformationsforschung, die wir betreiben, steckt natürlich in der Digitalisierung eine gewaltige Chance auf ganz vielen Ebenen.
Und inwiefern denken Sie sind da die wissenschaftlichen Institute als auch vor allem die Lehrbetriebe aufgestellt in der Hinsicht? Ich meine es wird viel geklagt.
Wir hatten das ja gerade auch schon, dass es schon erschreckend ist, dass die Institutionen, deren Kerngeschäft Umgang mit Wissen und Wissensproduktion ist, sich diesen neuen Technologien doch nur sehr sehr zaghaft nähern. Ich weiß als ich Ende der 90er Jahre in Oldenburg war, da gab es so erste Möglichkeiten, die Folien ins Netz zu stellen, so Audiomitschnitte zu machen und habe das dann sehr intensiv genutzt und dann kam aus 3-4 sehr pfiffige Studierende aus dem 2. Semester auf mich zu und sagten, Herr Schneidewind das ist schon ganz nett, aber wir wollen Ihnen mal ein Gefühl dafür geben, was da eigentlich geht. Und haben dann so eine Campusplattform programmiert, wo dann auch Studierendenbewertungen durchgeführt werden konnten. Und wenn mir überlege, was damals aus diesem Team Anfang der 00er Jahre schon da war und wie wenig sich seit dem in der weiten Verteilung entwickelt hat, wie groß die Kämpfe waren, dann überhaupt so was wie ein Lehrendenevaluation durchsetzen zu dürfen.
Weil man die unterstützen musste, weil alle versuchten, es zu verhindern. Dann ist man schon ein Stück erschreckt, wie schwerfällig der Umgänge mit diesen neuen Medien im Wissenschaftssystem passiert. Und man einfach nur hoffen kann, dass das was sich jetzt auch andeutet über ganz neue Formen der Arbeitsteilung, dass also all das was so klassische Grundlagenvorlesungen sind. Also wo es darum geht, Basis-KnowHow zu vermitteln, dass sich das zunehmend sehr viel leichter globalisiert über gute MOOCs vermitteln lässt und ich damit ganz andere Kapazitäten frei bekomme, um individuell in tutorieller Betreuung Studierende dort abzuholen, wo sie sich befinden, und heranzuführen. Und so klassische Vermittlung Vorlesungsformate eigentlich künftig komplett verschwinden könnten. Dass das auch wieder so ein bisschen wie so ein Erdbeben durch das System geht und wir die Art, wie wir diese Lern- und Wissensprozesse organisieren, radikal verändern.
Und das heißt ja nicht eine komplette Virtualisierung von Lehre, sondern die Konzentration auf das, wo der unmittelbare Kontakt mit Lehrenden und Begleitung wirklich didaktische Mehrwerte erzeugt und es Absonderung von dessen, wo es einfach sehr viel besser ist, ich höre mir eine didaktisch perfekt aufbereitete Vorlesung von einem der weltbesten Vordenker im Feld an, statt mich mit dem mittelmäßigen Professor vor Ort auseinandersetzen zu müssen und mich auf dessen Halbweisheiten einzulassen. Habe dann aber vor Ort Tutorinnen und Tutoren, die meine Lern- und Herkunftssituation kennen und mir helfen, dann an solchen Wissensprozessen teilzuhaben. Also da steckt eine Produktivitätsreserve in dem System, die glaube ich erst zu ganz wenigen Teilen gehoben ist.
Also Stichwort umgedrehtes Klassenzimmer, das spielt da mit rein. Wer noch nicht reingehört hat, hier Ausgabe 22 das Gespräch mit Jürgen Handke, dreht sich ganz konkret genau um solche Ansätze in der Lehre. Aber ich wollte nochmal einen anderen Aspekt aufrufen, um gerade sozusagen auch nochmal so ein bisschen die Lehren auch des digitalen Zeitalters, was ja gar nicht so neu ist, also es wird viel vom Neuland geredet, aber das gab es auch schon vor 20 Jahren und man fragt sich, was eigentlich passiert ist. Die atemberaubende Entwicklung des Webs, des Netzes insgesamt hat glaube ich dem einen oder anderen ausreichend Atem genommen, aber man hat ja auch immer mal wieder, also jetzt jenseits des Cyberspacehypes und der natürlich immer wieder damit aufkommenden Verheißung des Glücks und des Landes des ewigen Sonnenuntergangs etc. gibt es ja schon ein paar interessante Trends, die sagen wir mal die Digitalwelt so entwickelt hat.
Ich sage mal Open Source, überhaupt der Umgang mit freien Lizenzierungen. Eine extrem kritische Grundhaltung gegenüber dem Patentsystem und was ich jetzt insbesondere im Bereich der Lehre auch immer wieder als ein enormes Hindernis sehe und kennenlernen halt auch das Urheberrecht, was sich über lange Zeit gehalten hat, weil man einfach auch häufig da auch immer wieder Gründe, teilweise auch gut begründete Argumente finden, die halt einfach eine Offenlegung der Lehre, eine problemlose Verbreitung ... ja wenn ich jetzt meine Slides ins Netz stelle, dann werde ich für jeden Slide von fünf Leuten verklagt, weil es gibt da kein Fair Use und keine Ausnahmeklauseln für den Hochschulbetrieb. Also war das schon mal so ein Thema der Politik, sozusagen auch mal anzuraten, da so einen anderen Freiraum sozusagen zu bieten.
Auch was den Umgang mit wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten im Hinblick auf Open Science und freien Informationsaustausch betrifft? Das sozusagen der Politik vorzuschlagen, da so einen Schutzraum zu schaffen und zu sagen, das muss einfach in diesem Feld möglich sein, ohne Angst zu veröffentlichen in jeder Form und wie können wir das erreichen?
Ja das ist wirklich so eines glaube ich der Themen, das in den nächsten Jahren noch massiv auf uns zukommen wird. Weil da geht es ja letztlich um die Frage, wo finden die zentralen Wertschöpfungsprozesse statt und wer profitiert von ihnen? Und das ist ja hochinteressant. Wenn man das jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch nochmal beobachtet hat, wie führende Größen, auch aus diesen Industrien sagen, wir müssen, wenn wir das jetzt weitertreiben, auch über komplett neue Formen von Wohlstaats- und Sozialstaatsorganisation nachdenken. Der Timoteus Höttges ist der Chef der Telekom der hat gesagt, wir brauchen eine Debatte über das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen. Weil wir gerade durch diese Urheberrechts- und Sicherungsstrukturen es ja dazu beiträgt, dass heute diese gewaltigen Gewinner, die über diese Wertschöpfungsprozesse der neuen Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologien möglich werden, sich nur noch an einzelnen wenigen globalen Orten konzentrieren.
Und es gibt dort auch aus dem Umfeld des MITs, Brien Jolfs? Und McAfee haben eine wunderbare Studie geschrieben über the second machine age, in dem die auch deutlich machen, dass in dieser 0-Grenzkosten-Welt, in der ich dann Produkte eben zu 0 Kosten beliebig vervielfältigen kann, bei gleichzeitig der Tatsache, dass schon kleinste Unterschiede dazu beitragen, dass sich nur noch einer am Markt durchsetzt. Also es ist ja so, wenn Sie jetzt Maurer haben und der eine ist ein bisschen schlechter als der andere, dann sagen Sie dem schlechteren, ja gut pass mal auf, du brauchst immer bisschen länger als der andere, ich zahle dir einfach 20% weniger Stundenlohn und trotzdem kriegt der seinen Job. Überall werden Maurer gebraucht und der der schnell mauert, der kann auch einen höheren Preis durchsetzen, aber ich brauche viele Maurer. Wenn ein Entwickler ein bestimmtes Navigationssystem einen kleinen Tick effizienter macht als alle anderen und sich deswegen Google oder Amazon entscheidet, das auf ihre Plattform zu nehmen, ist das dann in schnellster Zeit das einzige Navigationssystem, das sich durchsetzt.
Und die ganzen ökonomischen Gewinne konzentrieren sich dort und werden dann angesichts dieser Unfähigkeit in der nationalen Koordination für Steuergesetzgebung auch noch nirgendwo versteuert. Weil durch geschickte Konzernverschachtelungen das so hinausgeht. Und Sie haben plötzlich gewaltige Kapitalakkumulation bei wenigen. Oxfam-Studie sagte ja gerade, 62 Menschen in dieser Welt besitzen so viel, wie die anderen 50% der ärmsten. Das wird weiter vorangehen und das führt natürlich dazu, dass die Gesellschaften auseinanderfliegen. Und da wird plötzlich klar, wenn wir da nicht Lösungen finden, wie wir entweder, wenn wir das so in diesen rein kommerzialisierten Strukturen durchhalten, Sozial- und Wohlfahrtstaat ganz anders organisieren. Sagen, okay das ist mit der Gewinnkonzentration okay, aber da werden 30% mal weggenommen und dann kriegt jeder Weltenbürger 1000 Euro im Monat Grundeinkommen und dann ist das auch völlig okay, dass die über Urheberrecht ihre Datenkarten sichern.
Oder wir kommen zu völlig neuen ökonomischen Modellen, die klar machen, nein diese Wissensbasis die muss Open Source sein und ich überlege mir, wie müssen Anreize eigentlich aussehen, dass da in so einem System überhaupt noch Innovationen stattfinden. Wo brauche ich überhaupt ökonomische Innovationen? So was wie Wikipedia, Linux und anderes, das ist ja dann auch in ganz anderen Motivationsstrukturen entstanden. Und da geht es wirklich in den Kern dessen, wie wir unser ökonomisches System der Zukunft organisieren. Und das hat, und darum beschäftigt uns das auch als Nachhaltigkeitsinstitut, natürlich sehr sehr viel dann auch zu tun, was sind die Wohlstandsverständnisse und Wohlstandsmuster der Zukunft. Denn das heutige Wohlstandsmuster läuft ja darauf hinauf, ich arbeite viel, ich verzichte auf viel und ein Teil der Droge, die ich bekomme, um diszipliniert mich im System zu bewegen, ist dann eben auch ein Konsum, den nur ich und sich nicht alle anderen erlauben können.
Und dieser Konsumismus ist ja eine ganz wichtige Triebfeder all der ökologischen Probleme, die wir haben. Also in der Welt, in der klar ist, da gibt es so was wie eine freizugängliche Sphäre, heißt ja oft so Novosphäre, der Wissensbestände, in denen ich mich austausche, das macht den Kern der Lebensqualität aus, werden dann vielleicht auch bestimmte Formen kompensatorischen, materiellen Konsums gar nicht mehr die gleiche Bedeutung haben. Also darum hängen diese Themen extrem eng zusammen und müssen glaube ich künftig auch noch viel intensiver zusammen gedacht werden.
Ich meine es geschieht ja schon so einiges, gerade was so das freie Wissen betrifft. Also ich sehe zumindest da Änderungen. Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel aus der Raumfahrt, das neue Kopernikus-Programm, die Erdbeobachtungssatelliten der neuen Generation, die jetzt gerade von der ESA abgesetzt werden, sammeln nicht nur sehr viele neue Daten mit modernsten Sensoriken, sondern stellen diese auch kostenlos zur freien Nutzung zur Verfügung. Schlicht aus dem Kalkül heraus, das bringt am Ende uns unseren Zielen näher, als wenn wir da irgendein kompliziertes Vornutzungsrecht macht, was dann eben auch wieder eng verwoben ist mit der Art und Weise zu publizieren bisher. Gut das muss sich jetzt erst nochmal beweisen, aber auch das würde ich jetzt mal als ein Beispiel dafür sehen, wie sich die Einstellung an der Stell auch schon ändert.
Schönes Beispiel ja. Das wäre auch im Hinblick jetzt auf den Umgang mit Produktdaten, auch dort gibt es ja über die europäische Chemikaliengesetzgebung eben die Verpflichtung, gewisse Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen, Auskunftsrechte einzuräumen. Und europäische Umweltorganisationen das auch sehr elegant genutzt haben, indem sie das dann umsetzen in Apps. Es gibt zum Beispiel so eine Toxfox-App vom Bund für Umwelt- und Naturschutz Deutschlands. Da kann man dann an jedes kosmetische Produkt herangehen und scannen und sagen, was ist da eigentlich drin und wenn es da noch keine Informationen gibt, auf einen Knopf drücken, an den in den Verkehr Bringer und den Hersteller sagen, bitte schickt mir die Informationen dazu und damit dann das entsprechende Informationsrecht ausgelöst wird. Und man also merkt, wenn man Verpflichtungen solchen öffentlichen Datenumgang schafft, sich da heute dann über unterschiedliche Akteure auch sehr sehr intelligente Auswertungsstrategien draufsetzen, die man vermutlich zentral hätte gar nicht erfinden können.
Und überall, wo solche offenen und frei verfügbaren Daten zur Verfügung stehen, schaffe ich eben überhaupt einen Fundus, so eines verantwortungsvollen Umgangs damit.
Ja aber ich meine, noch ist die Situation ja so ein bisschen absurd. Ich meine, wenn man da in die USA schaut, da gibt es jetzt seit 20 Jahren Softwareentwicklung an Universitäten, da ist viel Code erzeugt worden. Das MIT, viele andere Universitäten haben da großes beigetragen, nicht nur aber insbesondere auch gerade in der Entwicklung des Internets, freier Betriebssysteme. Und dieses Dogma, das was dort quasi mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert wurde im Rahmen der Ausbildung, dass das dann eben auch automatisch öffentlich verfügbar ist und von allen genutzt werden kann, hat ja der gesamt wirtschaftlichen und wissenschaftlichen Entwicklung extrem genutzt. Das ist hier noch keine Realität, stattdessen wird hier irgendwie darüber debattiert, wie man Urheberrechtsabgaben machen kann von ausgegebenen schriftlichen Notizen an Studenten, die die Lehrveranstaltung begleiten. Die dann noch im einzelnen noch nachgewiesen werden müssen.
Da dreht man sich doch halt irgendwie im Kreis. Also ich habe so den Eindruck, diese Debatte hat eigentlich noch gar nicht so richtig begonnen, dass man sich darüber klar macht, dass sozusagen Daten und sozusagen auch im Rahmen der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit an Universitäten gewonnene Werkzeuge, Instrumente und Leistungen eben auch in zunehmendem Maße einfach der Öffentlichkeit bereitgestellt werden sollten, bis hin eben zur Auswirkung auch auf urheberrechtsrechtliche Fragen. Dass das derzeit noch ein riesiger Hinderungsgrund ist, überhaupt in verschiedene Richtungen zu denken?
Ich meine das ist ja eine sehr sehr schwierige Debatte, wo man wirklich sich sehr genau in die einzelnen Bereiche hineinbegeben muss. Also wo erzeugen solche verlegerischen Leistungen auch einen wirklich eigenen Mehrwert und wo ist es hier einfach ein geschickter Lobbyismus, um ganz bestimmte ökonomische Bewertungsinteressen zu schützen. Ich meine das ist jetzt im Hinblick auf die Kerndebatte natürlich ein Feld, in dem wir jetzt nicht ganz aktiv unterwegs sind, sondern uns eher diese Fragen interessieren, wo führt freier Datenzugang eben wirklich auch dazu, nochmal ganz andere Steuerungsmöglichkeiten im Hinblick auf solche Aspekte wie nachhaltiger Entwicklung zu ermöglichen. Und da hatten Sie ja auch gerade einige der Themenbereiche angesprochen.
Aber auch diese Urheberrechtsdebatte ist eine, wo wir auch in so einem Institut wie unserem sehr genau fragen, was sind da eigentlich Ergebnisse, die wir bewusst OpenSource stellen, weil wir eben nicht möchten, dass es am Ende in einem referierten Zeitschriftenverlag landet, wo es dann notwendig ist, 30 Euro zu zahlen, wenn man den Aufsatz lesen will. Wir eigentlich das Ziel haben, mit unseren Erkenntnissen wirklich konkrete Veränderungsprozesse anzustoßen. Und da wir immer darauf achten, dass das was auch gesellschaftlich wirken soll, auch frei verfügbar ist.
Wo gibt es denn jetzt positive Entwicklungen? Also vielleicht können wir das ja auch ein bisschen weg von der Klage hin zu konkreten Änderungen, die sich schon abzeichnen. Mit welchen Hochschulen, Landesregierungen oder Stiftungen, Initiativen, können Sie da vielleicht auch ein paar nennen, wo – wenn wir jetzt mal vom Beispiel Botrop vielleicht wegkommen zu anderen Beispielen, - wo sich so dieser transformative Gedanke und die Notwendigkeit zum Wandel, der als Chance begriffen wird, auch schon manifestiert?
Ja ich meine wir sind durchaus auch positiv überrascht und man sieht, das ist jetzt so eine Thematik, die ja eigentlich seit fast 20 Jahren im Raum ist, mit all dem was über Transdisziplinarität diskutiert wurde. Anfang der 90er Jahre, Mitte der 90er diese Hochphase hatte und dann so ein Stück eingeschlafen war, jetzt doch gelungen ist, in den letzten fünf Jahren da viele Impulse auszulösen. Sie sprachen das an, es gibt gerade so einige Landesregierungen, die auch in ihrer Wissenschaftspolitik das sehr aktiv aufgegriffen haben, da Akzente setzen. Nordrhein-Westfalen sehr umfassendes Programm „Fortschritt NRW“, das genau versucht, so ein erweitertes Fortschrittsverständnis dann in unterschiedliche Programme zu übersetzen. Die Baden-Württembergische Landesregierung hat so ein ganzes Programm „Wissenschaft für Nachhaltigkeit“ aufgelegt. Und in dem Rahmen, wir sprachen darüber, große Zahl solcher Reallabore geschaffen. Auch in Niedersachsen gibt es unter der aktuellen Landesregierung jetzt ein ganz eigenes Programm „Wissenschaft für Nachhaltigkeit“, das mit der VW-Stiftung auf den Weg gebracht wurde.
Die VW-Stiftung hat ja als Forschungsstiftung damals schon den Club of Rome-Bericht 72 sehr aktiv mit unterstützt und greift jetzt so ein Stück auch dieser innovativen Impulse jetzt in diesen Fragen auch auf. Es gibt in Nordrhein-Westfalen die Stiftung Mercator, die sehr bewusst experimentiert, auch mit ganz anderen Formaten, um an dieser Schnittstelle Wissenschaft, Gesellschaft, Impulse auszulösen. Hat ja für den Prozess Energiewende, jetzt auch für die Frage der Verkehrswende so eigene Agoras eingerichtet, wo Wissenschaft und politische Akteure, die die Dinge diskutieren. Und auch im Bundesforschungsministerium, also in der Abteilung für nachhaltige Entwicklung, hat man sich eigentlich jetzt dieser Debatte durchaus geöffnet und experimentiert mit vielen Formaten. Die Hightech-Strategie, die ursprünglich sehr technologisch reduziert angelegt war, da kommt jetzt viel auch dieser mehr interdisziplinären Impulse mit hinein. Und versucht auch mit neuen Beteiligungsformaten zu arbeiten. Dass man schon spürt an vielen Stellen wird das Signal gehört.
Weil man auch merkt, dass man da mit der Wahrnehmung von Wissenschaft in der Gesellschaft einen hohen Gefallen tut und es kommen da Dinge in Bewegung. Wie skizziert, da ist noch große Schritte notwendig, aber man schon spürt, da sind Knospen da und erste Entwicklungen existieren.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt so in die Situation eines angehenden jungen Wissenschaftlers/Wissenschaftlerin versetzen, was würden Sie denn raten, wo man mal den Daumen drauflegen sollte. Also einerseits, nach welchen Angeboten sollte man vielleicht, die es jetzt schon gibt, Ausschau halten, beziehungsweise in Ermangelung dieser oder auch alternativ dazu, was für Wege würden sich denn anbieten, auch Einfluss zu nehmen und vielleicht einfach auch mal irgendwo den Daumen so in die Wunde zu legen, um einfach mal extra Schmerz zu erzeugen, um sagen wir mal eben zum Beispiel diese Inderdisziplinarität in der Ausbildung mehr zu genießen oder auch andere Vorteile aufzunehmen, die wir jetzt hier schon debattiert haben, die potentiell hilfreich sein könnten?
Ja ich meine da gibt es eben sehr unterschiedliche Wege. Das eine ist, bewusst auch an diese Orte zu gehen, wo das heute schon praktiziert wird. Wir sprachen über solch Universitäten wie die Leuphaner Universität, weil wenn solche Orte viele brillante Studierende haben, dann ist das natürlich auch etwas was hilft, diesen Ansätzen zum Durchbruch zu verhelfen. Wenn also die die das System in 10-15 Jahren prägen sagen, ja klar habe ich mal an der Leuphaner angefangen, weil das das war, was meinem Wissensverständnis entsprach, dann stabilisiert das natürlich auch entsprechende Entwicklungen. Ein andere Weg, der auch von vielen engagierten Studierenden gegangen wird und zur Zeit viel Bewegung auslöst ist, gezielt sich zusammenzutun und auch Widerstand zu organisieren. Wir haben das aktuell in den Wirtschaftswissenschaften, wo es Netzwerke gibt, wie das der pluralen Ökonomik, wo die Studierenden nicht mehr bereit sind, sich damit abzufinden, was sie an zum Teil ganz enger wirtschaftswissenschaftlicher Lehre präsentiert bekommen und dann selber Lesekreise einrichten.
Sich Gastvortragende einladen und sagen, na gut dann machen wir uns die ökonomische Ausbildung und das was wir eigentlich aus dem Studium ziehen wollten selber und gehen auch ganz offen in die wissenschaftspolitische Diskussion und fordern eine andere Form von Wirtschaftswissenschaft ein. Also das ist was, was dann auch die Hochschulen auch nicht unberührt lässt, weil sie am Ende ja nun auch zum großen Teil dafür da sind, dass das was da 18-19Jährige als Orientierungssuche haben, dass sie dafür Angebote bieten. Und ich glaube, das löst durchaus Veränderung aus. Es gibt auch Netzwerk N, das sind Studierende, die sich an vielen Orten in Nachhaltigkeitsinitiativen organisieren und sehr aktiv einfordern, dass sich an ihrer Hochschule mehr auch interdisziplinär in Richtung Nachhaltigkeit tut. Also ich glaube, das ist eben wichtig in so einer Welt, in der die eigentlichen Wissensvorräte immer freier und beliebig erreichbar zur Verfügung stehen, kommt es ja darauf an, welchen Kompass du entwickelst.
Und da sollte man sich sehr sehr stark auch auf seine Stimme verlassen, auf die spannenden Fragen, auf die Fragen, die einen beschäftigen und sich nicht einreden lassen, dass die Frage falsch ist und man jetzt erst mal was ganz anderes lernen muss, sondern sich Orte und Organisationsformen suchen, die einem helfen, die Fragen, die einen bewegen, weiter zu spezifizieren und mit denjenigen, die ähnliche Fragen beschäftigen, zusammenzutun. Und dann sehr gezielt vom System das auch einzufordern. Ich glaube das ist ein extrem guter Kompass, weil der Engpass im 21. Jahrhundert ist nicht das verfügbare Wissen, sondern ist der Fundus an den richtig gestellten Fragen, den richtigen Perspektiven, die auf uns zukommen. Und das entsteht nur in einem Klima von Offenheit und Inspiration. Da sollte man sich auch ein bisschen vom Bauchgefühl her leiten lassen.
Also immer wenn man das Gefühl hat, man wird jetzt hier intellektuell abgerüstet und eingezwängt durch vermeintliche Regeln eines Wissenschaftsbetriebs und einer Disziplin, das ist schon ein Anzeichen dafür, dass das der eigenen intellektuellen Entwicklung nicht wirklich gut tut.
Ich wittere hier auch eine Chance für so ein bisschen immer etwas geschlagene Wissenschaftsbereiche, also ich meine vor allem jetzt konkret die Geisteswissenschaften und im speziellen würden mir jetzt auch gerade die Wissenschaftshistoriker einfallen. Ein Thema was wir auch hier in der Serie schon mal hatten, wo auch gerade aus den Gesprächen immer wieder herausklang, ja so viele Fehler werden auch wieder gemacht, weil einfach die Geschichte  nicht ausreichende gekannt wurde und sagen wir mal die Wissenschaftsgeschichte als solche einfach gar nicht so präsent ist, auch ein Opfer dieser Spezialisierung, wo wir sozusagen nicht nur so ... man hat ja immer so das Gefühl, Wissenschaftshistoriker und so die sitzen dann da und machen so ihre historischen Diashows, wie schön es doch war damals bei Isaac Newton und jetzt haben wir uns alle ein bisschen gefreut, ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit geschaut zu haben.
Weil es eigentlich sehr viel mehr darum geht sozusagen eben auch an der Stelle interdisziplinär zu sein im Sinne von nicht nur die Erfahrung meiner kontemporären Wissenschaftler, sondern eben auch interdisziplinär eben auch die Erfahrung, auch positive wie negative Erfahrung im historischen Bild. Und natürlich was Sie ja auch schon ansprachen, dass gerade in so interdisziplinären Fachgruppen eben auch die Verbindung mit Philosophen zum Beispiel auch eine Technikphilosophie etc. ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt sein kann, einfach auch um den Blickwinkel auch auf die Wichtigkeit oder Unwichtigkeit der eigenen Disziplin ganz anders zu öffnen.
Absolut. Also gerade dieser historische Dimension und dieses Denken in grundsätzlichen Kategorien das ist natürlich etwas, was in diesen komplett durchökonomisierten Periode, in der wir uns befinden, zunehmend heraus und abtrainiert wird. Weil was heißt Ökonomie? Ökonomie ist ja eine Wissenschaft, die ja komplett geschichts- und zeitlos, da geht es ja immer nur um das Herstellen von Gleichgewichten, basierend auf aktualisierten aktuellen Präferenzen. Das heißt ich gucke immer nur, wie schaffe ich in einem ökonomischen System einen Ausgleich, mit dem was ich gerade in mir als ein Bedürfnis artikuliert und wie baue ich das gesamte System? Und damit geht alles, was jetzt das Individuum transzendiert und seine Bedürfnisse und eine historische Perspektive radikal verloren. Und ich glaube dieser Blick genau auf diese übergeordneten Kategorien, das ist eine ganz zentrale Frage, und ich glaube das spüren eben gerade diese offenen kritischen orientierten Studierenden und Jugendlichen.
Die merken, nee also das was mir da präsentiert wird, liefert mir eigentlich keine Antworten, um einzuordnen, was ein Kompass sein kann, hier am Anfang des 21. Jahrhunderts, um eine wirkliche Orientierung dann auch zu haben. Und es ist dann wirklich bitter, dass gerade so was wie Theoriegeschichte, Wissenschaftsgeschichte, aber auch die disziplinären Theoriegeschichten fast komplett von den Hochschulen abgebaut wurden. Da hat man dann lieber noch einen modernen Teiltrends abbildenden Lehrstuhl geschaffen und genau dieses Reflexionswissen eher zurückgebaut. Und ich glaube die Vorreiterstandorte wird auszeichnen, dass sie das eher stärken, als dass sie es noch weiter reduzieren.
Wie stark ist denn die Arbeit des Wuppertal-Instituts so in Deutschland beheimatet? Also ist natürlich dort beheimatet, aber reden wir die ganze Zeit von so einem spezifischen deutschen Blick auf die deutsche Wissenschaftslandschaft oder inwiefern sind da auch europäische internationale Aspekte der Wissenschaft von Lehrentwicklung drin unterhalten?
Nee das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig, dass man bei dem Thema sich das international anschaut und die Trends sind da sehr unterschiedlich, also man stellt in der amerikanischen Wissenschaft, sagen wir angelsächsisch geprägten, fest, dass einerseits da durchaus sehr viel weniger Berührungsängste da sind, Wissenschaft und nichtwissenschaftliches Wissen aufeinander zu beziehen. Transfer funktioniert ja sehr sehr viel besser. Auf der anderen Seite sind Teildisziplinen wie die Wirtschaftswissenschaften im angelsächsischen Bereich dann noch viel dogmatischer oft geschlossen. Und dennoch lassen sich auch im angelsächsischen Bereich für diese Themen, die uns beschäftigen, einzelne Vorreiterinstitutionen finden. Arizona State University zum Beispiel und Phoenix ist da auch global ein Taktgeber. Was interessant ist ist der Blick auf die Wissenschaft in vielen Ländern sozusagen des globalen Südens und den sich jetzt dynamisch entwickelnden Schwellenländern.
Die sind natürlich zum Teil noch sehr sehr stark geprägt von der Wissenschaftslogik der entwickelten Industrieländer. Oft auch mit einem sehr starken technologischen Bios. Da ist es dann für die jungen Leute das größte, auch in Natur- und Ingenieurwissenschaften zu gehen, da dann auch Karriere mit den ökonomischen Entwicklungsambitionen zu machen. Und wenn wir uns jetzt aber die zentralen Herausforderungen anschauen und sagen, ja wie sieht eigentlich Stadtentwicklung in diesen neuen globalen Megacities Asiens oder Afrikas aus. Da geht es ja nicht im Kern um pfiffige Hightech-Lösungen, sondern da geht es wirklich darum, wie schaffe ich es, soziale Integration, die Ungleichheitsdynamiken durch intelligente Formen von Stadtgestaltung, gesellschaftlicher Entwicklung in den Griff zu bekommen. Und da stellen wir ja heute fest, dass wir jetzt beginnen zum Teil von südamerikanischen Metropolen zu lernen.
Also wie ich so was intelligent organisiere und es aber noch nicht das Selbstbewusstsein der Wissenschaft dort vor Ort gibt. Zu sagen, wir sitzen eigentlich auf Wissensschätzen, die wir auch verfügbar machen können für diese globale Debatte. Sondern immer noch so ein Gefälle da ist, am Ende zählt nur eins, ob man in Oxford oder Stanford landet. Und da haben wir eben auch eine sehr intensive Debatte im internationalen Kontext zu einer ganz anderen Kultur der gleichen Augenhöhe, dieser verschiedenen Wissenszugänge zu haben. Und ich glaube, da ist einfach zu hoffen, dass auch die Wissenschaft und die Wissensbestände, die gerade in den Ländern des globalen Südens existieren, in ihrer Bedeutung für die Entwicklung im 21. Jahrhundert auch anerkannt werden und wir uns nicht nur vertikal in einer Reihe einordnen, die eben in Standford beginnt und dann in irgendeiner Provinzuniversität in der Mongolei endet.
Denn das was da zum Teil an Wissensproduktion vielleicht in dieser Provinzuniversität passiert für eine globale und nachhaltigkeitsgerechte Entwicklung viel wichtiger sein kann als irgendeine Hightech-Entwicklung in Stanford oder am MIT.
Ja es reicht nicht, nur die Sonnenliege im Elfenbeinturm anders auszurichten, um mehr Sonne zu bekommen, weil sie sich mit der Zeit etwas verschattet hat. Sondern raus auf die grüne Wiese und mal wieder mit den anderen Kindern spielen, um da sozusagen die Perspektive zu erhalten.
Schönes Bild.
Ja das ist ein sehr auf sehr vielen Ebenen greifendes Bild so. Und ich merke auch, dass einfach die Nachhaltigkeit einfach mittlerweile eben auch weit von dieser reinen Umwelt- und Überlebensdebatte hinausgegangen ist und eigentlich grundsätzlich so ein bisschen zu so einem Leitbild der menschlichen Entwicklung an sich so, aber eben in diesem Fall konkret eben auch der wissenschaftlichen Ausrichtung wird und dass wahrscheinlich alle Beteiligten noch mehr lernen müssen, sich auch daran zu orientieren.
Absolut. Und wir haben ja gerade im letzten Jahr diesen neuen Sustainable Developement Goals, also die Nachhaltigkeitsziele auf UN-Ebene für die kommenden 15 Jahre so als Kompass festgelegt und das besondere daran ist ja, dass eben in dieser Debatte gemeinsam gedacht wird. Also die Frage, wie erzeuge ich gutes Leben, Lebensqualität mit all den Fragen von Bildung, von ausreichender Basisversorgung, über Beteiligungsmuster und bringe das zusammen mit dem Wissen um diese ökologisch planetarischen Grenzen. Und das ist im Kern eben Nachhaltigkeit, beides zusammen zu denken. Und das entscheidende dessen, was auch letztes Jahr passiert ist, dass man diese Wohlstandsdimension eben nicht mehr nur als eine Entwicklungsdimension sieht, nach dem Motto, da muss jeder etwas zu essen haben und eine Basisgrundversorgung sanitär, sondern diese Wohlstandsdimension noch ganz ganz viel mit den Wohlstandsmodellen in der industrialisierten Welt zu tun hat. Sozusagen auch dort müssen wir über neue Formen des Wohlstands diskutieren.
Weil dieser auf reinen materiellen und immer weiter wachsenden materiellen Konsum ausgerichtete Wohlstand in den Industrieländern ist das, was uns tatsächlich gewaltige Probleme erzeugt. Die Ungleichheiten, aber auch die ökologischen Probleme. Und darum sind im Hinblick auf die Wohlstandsdimensionen gerade USA, Deutschland und ganz andere Länder die eigentlichen Entwicklungsländer und auch da findet so ein Umdenken statt, das von zentraler Bedeutung ist.
Entwicklungsland Deutschland, es gibt noch viel zu tun. Herr Schneidewind vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zu den Gedankengebäude transformative Wissenschaft. So kann man es glaube ich nennen.
Auch von meiner Seite vielen Dank, hat Spaß gemacht.
Und ja vielen Dank hier auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, das war jetzt auch sicherlich nicht der letzte Beitrag zu Aspekten der Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte, aber wir werden auch natürlich andere Gebiete demnächst hier wieder durchforsten, und das gibt es dann alles beim nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder Forschergeist. Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.